we have new be good to yourself teas in
summertime colorways like banana salmon
and more check them out at
theovonstore.com baby get that hitter
today's guest is back for her third time
um we've had some real moments
and um and she has a new special coming
up on hbo called good clean filth
uh i am i really i loved this
conversation and i think you're gonna
love it too
uh it is my friend comedian miss nikki
glazer
[Music]
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
just
all right
nikki glazer good to see you good to see
you too theo vaughn yeah being alive how
what's going on
just in town you know
yeah doing press stuff like that got a
special coming out oh you do have boy
island two also coming out
okay right and so both of those are on
netflix uh hbo okay max
yeah oh yeah they're back like i didn't
plan it this way but um
my special was supposed to come out in
march i shot it in november and i don't
know about you but like i can't
watch myself ever
i hate looking at myself so the editing
process was so
tedious and i put it off so much that it
had to be pushed to july because i
couldn't get it edited in time because i
couldn't watch myself it's i literally
was like frozen have you ever felt that
way about watching your stand up
yeah i always i mean i feel sometimes
like i don't
it's just such a tough way to capture
stand up and to try and get it right
in a
like in a or just get the exact thing
you want in a night um even though you
get two chances for some reason i make
the state same mistakes twice and you go
why couldn't i just
i've done it the way i always do it it's
like
it's um i never but i never listen to
myself and i never watch myself after
that's why i like stand up you just do
it and then you like it was live
if anyone like calls you one like oh
this thing you did wasn't good you can
go well in my head it was there's no
proof of like
you can't analyze it
yeah i get oh i think there's
i think there's well that's something
that i felt like was always nice about
everything you know
like
you used to never
be able to analyze everything it was
like
you know i think about this sometimes
like a moment used to have so much value
like there's no real
like a moment feels like it doesn't have
value anymore like a real moment because
like if it's not captured it it started
to feel like hey don't capture this but
it used to be like hey don't capture
this this is important this is like
you know put your cameras away yeah and
now it's like hey let's not have this
conversation until we get rolling yeah
like we just sat in silence here like we
didn't want to have any kind of any
friendship and no there was like a a
nice greeting and then it was like let's
just save it
but there's something nice about that
because we want to be
we want it to be genuine we want people
to see like what is really going on
right like us we want to save our our
actual energy so people can see okay
this is when they really started talking
because you and i didn't talk about i
stood up i gave you a hug yeah you sat
down
and then we waited yeah and then we
waited it's like we wait until
okay i did like a meditation kind of for
however like it was like a minute really
kind of just
yeah because on the way over i was
planning on doing a meditation then i
get lost in my phone
and so i had a couple seconds while the
tvs were being set everything was set up
and i just was like just focus on your
breathing i did with my eyes open
obviously because that would be weird
but do that hard kegel baby push some
freaking just tense up everything like
oh yeah
like just i don't i don't know what i
did but i just centered myself and i was
just like whatever happens happens
and don't regret anything you say it
happened for a reason anything you don't
say
it was meant to not be said all that
[ __ ]
yeah it gets scary i used to feel less
scary about podcasting and then i think
i started to just get in my head so much
me too yeah
wait why
hmm we should be more free i know cause
we have more people watching
yeah you know i don't know what it is i
think some yeah someone probably became
that some of it could have been ego for
me i don't or fear
you know because i think ego is really
ego is just like
fear in like a nice cape with a comb
yeah you know um
but what's your fear like what's your
fear with podcasting if you could kind
of
pinpoint what's the what's the thing you
have now what's your like biggest fear i
always like to do that like okay what's
my biggest fear okay then what happens
and then what happens oh yeah i think
it's that people sho all your life you
know i think you want you know
even if you don't realize that you're
seeking as a comedian maybe you're
seeking validation and then they show up
and you're afraid they're gonna leave
you know yes or they're gonna look
closely and go oh wait this is not
what i thought it was yeah this is yeah
yeah this guy's a perv or this guy's a
you know yeah loiterer yeah a what
loiterer
just hanging out
oh yeah dude i used to do a ton of
lawyer and that was a big thing in our
area because they didn't have a lot to
do
so those signs were directed at you
because i always wondered who's just
loitering like what does it even mean
soliciting loitering those signs i never
really understood we didn't solicit i
admire the solicitors at least they had
they were making money
yeah we was out there [ __ ] middling
around bro just freaking feeling our
penis between our legs you know or not
feeling not touching it but just you
know we were just out there just you
know just seeing what the wind had to
say you know just out there just milling
around like you kind of stand in front
of the post office and act like you
[ __ ] owned it or something just
[ __ ] yeah and no phones i mean
that's what loitering no phones just
staring into the air
yes
yeah what did we do i know that's like a
very cliche question nowadays but what
did we do
when we were waiting for something
well you know it's interesting because
i'll notice sometimes i'll have feelings
like if i go eat by myself sometimes
i'll leave my phone in the car now and
it's like all right dude i'm just gonna
see what god wants you know what i'm
saying baby i'm gonna be out there you
know i'm gonna be out of here
in mother nature's laundromat but you
know what i'm saying with no coins you
know i'm gonna see what could happen i
can see doing that with a friend but
like by yourself and what do you what do
you do well here's the part that feels
crazy the crazy part is
when you think okay if other people look
over here
and i'm just
thinking or looking into space
i now seem like a s like a crazy person
yeah i seem like someone oh that guy's
not
that guy's not doing well that guy is
just got kicked out of the church it's
that kind of look you know like oh why
would a man be eating by himself with no
phone with no phone unless he was
um unless he didn't know about phones or
he lost someone he wasn't you know
he couldn't fiscally afford to keep his
phone yeah and but you're nicely dressed
too which is confusing as well because
no phone should match a different look
and that's where then i think people go
oh he was with the church he got let go
and he's sitting here in shame um or
just got out of prison
yeah maybe i don't i don't i hard to get
a phone
i i don't think i have that look no but
you fee that's when i notice i'm like oh
my god if i sit here
what is the feeling is it a feeling that
i'm missing out or that um
no it's that that doesn't feel normal
anymore no and that used to feel real
normal yes
you know the chinese pull this up
zachary the chinese um
if you
take their picture they get angry at you
what do you mean like just
like a stranger no something more like
do china
want us taking their picture do
china yeah do the chinese there we go
like getting their picture taken yeah
let's [ __ ] be realistic
okay
[Music]
well i understand not wanting your
picture taken if you don't know it i
used to do that on on
the subway oh that's interesting then
why do chinese people take photos
everything i remember just being in
china i wonder if maybe it was malaysia
and we tried to take a picture and they
said no and i remember our teachers
would teach us that they don't like
their picture take cause it captures
the soul who believes that picture
taking captures the soul mate there you
go that's that's the good
who believes
pictures capture the soul
damn kind of close to malaysian but not
but do you feel like over time okay
yeah
and the mayans who knows what they were
you ever see do you ever see a picture
of yourself where you don't know what's
being taken and you have just a look
where you're like whoa i that my soul is
in that where you just have like a dead
look that just a moment that captures
like really what you're feeling in that
moment
like you just you don't know like um
where it's just uh i think we have these
things i've learned about it in some
class i took once where i was paying
attention and um you have flashes
we as humans need to communicate and
they're
like microseconds long but it will show
i could be like smiling in such a good
mood if i'm in a bad mood you for a
flash you'll see my real truth of like
discomfort or
anger or whatever it is and it's just a
quick flash but it's enough to send the
person that you're talking to the
message without them actually knowing
that you did it um and sometimes those
pictures catch that but mine's usually
just like a dead stare just like
yeah just kind of sad kind of a sadness
do you get sad
i mean who doesn't
oh yeah i spent too much time getting
sad i realized i realized i was getting
sad and then i was
uh
getting stuck in my own sadness you know
i was like
why am i sad i was asking that too much
instead of just doing things to not be
sad man i was just about to ask you what
makes you sad so i don't know if you
want to answer that but like you've
given a lot of thought like what's
something that'll go
trigger it and go
you know spiral
we see something
loneliness i think probably
uh getting older sometimes seeing people
with families if i don't have a family
that kind of stuff sometimes
you know like
uh but then you really like kind of look
at that you know and you're like oh that
kid's going to prison in [ __ ] seven
years like i do not want little jonathan
you know that's
um yeah but i do think it's interesting
how it's like almost that we
like even friendships now it's like
recorded and put out people it's like
i wonder if in like 20 years people will
listen back and like oh listen to these
friendships on tape you know oh yeah
it'll be like or you know oh wow let's
go listen to some friendships like or
like human like if podcasting if it gets
to the point where humans don't interact
anymore oh yeah
what does it sound like when they used
to talk to each other yes or what is it
like um oh what about a hug let's go
look at some old videos of people
hugging
you know or somebody tickling somebody
you know oh my god do you like being
tickled
i don't mind it dude but when i was
growing up they had uh i miss tickling
tickling was such a part of childhood
getting pinned down yeah i used to love
doing it i used to look like there's
something about
it's though it's the worst feeling in
the world and a lot of the porn
sometimes when i'm watching porn
there'll be like tickling videos and i
have no interest in that it's not like a
sexual thing but i guess it's a whole
genre of porn the tickling stuff yeah it
relates like just people tied up being
like
like laughing girls oh yeah i hate it
what now what do what do you think you
um
what do you think you don't like about
tickling i mean i used to love it as a
kid because i think it was probably just
like touch
yeah like it was just like i i don't
think i got enough as a kid i really
didn't i
my mom hates when i say this on things
but i just don't think i got enough
human touch yeah so i think i liked when
me and my cousins or me and my sister
would tickle i would used to love to
like wrestle i just wanted like to be
touched and like someone trying to get
me
yeah yeah tickling felt like somebody i
think was gonna be able to like uh i
think it started to feel like when does
it end it's almost too much
yes it's too it feels too exciting
there's a mix of like it feels too
exciting
i'm gonna [ __ ] i think there's a little
bit of that oh yeah you might like fart
yeah something like that like somebody's
gonna get the truth out of me like yeah
oh yeah a sound or something's going to
come out of you laugh why do we laugh
with tickling why is that it's so weird
i think i it's that a sound's going to
come out of me that i don't want someone
to hear that i didn't create so
vulnerable
i guess that's really vulnerable yeah it
i do compare it though to i always used
to say
that tickling was like masturbation in
the sense that if someone else does it
to me i'm laughing i can't i can't
control it but if i do it to myself
really i feel stupid i'm just like i see
it coming i think part of sex is like or
part of being turned on or
is the unexpected ooh
you know what i mean so i i now i don't
struggle with it as much but like i
never really understood why people how
people could masturbate and not
see it coming and in the same way that
like this doesn't do anything to me but
if anyone would do this to me i'd be
like da like i would how is that because
i can predict it
so reservation i'm like i can't i know
what's gonna happen here
yeah masturbation gets kind of uh
masturbation really runs its course you
know i met this guy one time at a
library and she had she didn't have any
fingers on one of her hands she had like
a
um
i don't know what it was called a nub
yeah but it was more almost like when
you do uh crab legs and you get all the
go on you take all the legs off the
crabs and it's almost like a little just
like the
hand meaty part it was like that thing
that thor has now i just saw it the
other day
what is it i just saw the movie though
that super hammer
yeah this gal had a real super hammer on
her and uh bring up tom dempsey too if
you can bring him up he's a famous guy
what is what does this have to do with
masturbation
well so i remember i met this guy at the
library and then we wanted to get
together bring him up there you go met a
girl at the library when is this theo
this was nine years ago okay
i love that it's not 10.
but that's tom dempsey right there is
he's got that freaking hammer look at
that claw hammer
zoom in on that hoof baby that's crazy
he died unfortunately mm-hmm
and he had to he hit a 73-yarder okay i
know he died at 73. so you met this girl
at the library nine years ago right and
i remember she would like kind of like
and we got involved in sex right yeah
and so she would like kind of
like pick up a girl at the library
how do you pick up a girl anywhere and
then get involved in sex i really don't
understand this
you just have a vibe did you know right
away like
this is happening no i sat down and she
was kind of cute and we were talking we
both were in the library so right there
you know things probably weren't going
great at the
overall i think if you're at the l
during you know at that time you know
the library hasn't been like a real
hotbed of that's why i asked the
timeline because i go nine years ago
yeah even then
yeah it was there's phones around and
especially even in los angeles man a lot
of the library out here is just a lot of
people i mean as we saw a dude try to
climb into a [ __ ] book this [ __ ]
homeless dude
tried to get into one of those big
atlases you know trying to take a
vacation the long way you know
but uh she she would like play with
herself kind of i remember this girl
would like kind of play with herself
with her and she had us a stump with her
uh unlimited hand she would kind of play
with herself
and then she would kind of
this isn't she would kind of like beat
this like beat the top of her
uvular whatever it's called she would
like hit it with the club with the uh
it was almost like a damn like treble
and bass you know it was like she was
like remixing her own puss kind of it
was
i mean i don't know
i don't know what happened oh and then i
remember it was like
it was a
it did you know a lot of women sometimes
some women will have
it just it had a
very
uh
violent
odor to her vagina oh yeah every time
she'd hit it with that hammer it just
i knew another like
waft oh i knew it was gonna be a lot of
you know man my toes would just curl up
and i was like i can't be a i can't be a
part of this so was this something this
is a one-time thing or was it a repeat
thing and you noticed that this odor was
not getting remedied
um i can't remember if it was one time
or two times yeah but it we ended up
separating right because voter you think
it was just a lot it was a lot of stuff
i think we didn't really get along that
great and we barely even knew each other
i mean we literally met at the library
and then were
you know trying to get involved sexually
how do you go i'm i'm not being like
obtuse about this i really need to know
how you go from library talking to like
let's go have sex did it
did it go did you go on a date did you
go like was it was there just something
in the air that you both knew you were
gonna have sex with each other like i
don't understand i think we might have
met for a drink okay something or a
coffee okay maybe uh
and then did you ask her about what
happened here like how long before you
found out no i don't like to ask about
that kind of stuff i usually say
something like oh i think it's pretty
cool you have like a unique hand or you
have a you know like you have a
you don't have a leg or something i
think that kind of stuff's kind of
fascinating sometimes oh i love it yeah
but i like the story behind it because i
think most people don't ask them and so
i like to go ahead and go what's going
on there
but that's a scary question to like
yeah and maybe i didn't you know i don't
know but i like that you you at least
acknowledged it you know a lot of uh
there's a lot of wireless providers that
forget how a family is made
they forget they just they're not
thinking of that they're thinking of
individual users
but mint mobile
is doing it differently
they decided to shake up the wireless
industry with their brand new modern
family plan
each line starts at 15 bucks a month and
you only need two lines to get started
no matter how big or small your family
is you deserve to save on wireless
service
for anyone who hates their phone bill
mint mobile
they're offering
wireless for just 15 bucks a month
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text and high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network
and mint mobile's modern family plan
lets you mix and match data plans
so everyone gets the amount of data
that's right for them because a baby
don't need a million gigabytes baby a
baby might need six gigabytes get a
breast emailed or get a milk email
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month including the modern
family plan
go to mint mobile.com
theo that's m-i-n-t
m-o-b-i-l-e
dot com slash t-h-e-o cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at mint
mobile.com slash theo you know debt is
something that's
it weighs on you
you know you're working your job and
you're you got your hourly pay or you
got your salary and you're just thinking
man
some of this is already gone
i don't like that feeling i don't like
that
i don't like that dirty dracula of debt
that's just sucking
things out of me in the distance
if you have high interest debt
it can be even harder to ask for help
but help is here upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt
all online
with simple and easy to understand
payment terms that's right
upstart has helped over 1.8 million
customers on their path to financial
freedom they'll do it
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars without impacting your
credit score that's key
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com
theo
get a better interest rate for yourself
at
upstart.com
theo
check your rate don't forget to use our
url loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and other certain information
provided in your loan application it's
not all about that credit score it's not
all about your income they take into
account more than that go to upstart.com
theo
okay so so you met for a drink and okay
that makes more sense to me because i
feel like some people just meet and they
just like no
and then they just start going at it
like i've never understood if you get a
like if you get a hooker like if my i
don't know why like if you get an escort
my friends that have done that i'm
always fascinated like what so they walk
in
who makes the first who makes the first
move
do now that i understand it and i've
asked questions i guess they come in
and they sit down on the bed next to you
and they just start like rubbing your
leg and then
things usually progress from there but
like that first moment of like going
from like hello to like
touching each other's genitals and like
kissing i don't know how that happens
most of them they seem like take their
gum out first
and then
do you talk about what's gonna happen
before in the the rate
or is that all i mean look for me it's
happened when i've been high on cocaine
i get out i started interviewing hookers
or whatever online or whatever and then
next thing you know you're
you know the saddest is when you're like
you're negotiating the rate that's like
this for like 75 bucks off and you're
like this is
this is not gonna end well you know i
want to hook up with someone that's like
oh god this guy's so ch like i'm giving
him a discount
doesn't that take something out of it
i'd want to pay more i think yeah that's
well that's an overall great attitude
you know i i just you know i but i guess
when you're high on cocaine you're not
making the best decisions yeah and i
didn't have any money when i was right
right right okay that makes sense and so
then yeah i think uh yeah but usually
they take their gum out one of them was
real angry one time
and i just paid her to not be just to go
it just and a lot of times for me i get
it's like
it's
i get so i'm so out like
i'm so like um kind of freaked out by
the time of the year because you have to
like hide everything it's it's alarming
yeah and you have a long time before
they show up so the impulse to like
i'm horny i'm high
i haven't come over then 45 minutes an
hour passes and in that time sometimes
are you like
are you can you sustain that excitement
and then they show up and you're like i
have to do this you're kind of like i
think it's a lot of fear and they a lot
of times seem like they're wasted or
something i'm trying to do they look a
lot of times what they look like in the
ad or
no it's definitely more of a
um
ross it's more like you get like the
ross version of whatever
you kind of like was in the photos a lot
of times but then it's just people don't
want to put their real cells out you
know yeah that makes sense but yeah most
of the time you know and i've even
talked to a lot of them they say it's
like a lot of uh
you know a lot of guys it's a lot of
guys that are high and then they go over
and there's not even a lot of sexual
interaction a lot of times so because
when you're cooked up doesn't you're
you're yeah you can't weiner day is not
doing anything you convince yourself it
is gonna work even though coke dick
everyone knows that's the thing and
obviously you've probably had it happen
before
is that not in your is your performance
level even a factor or is it just like
i'm paying for this so it can be
whatever i want it to be
i think do you want to show them a good
time are you trying to make them come
are you trying to like stand out as a
client i'm just thinking like what would
go through my head of like i want this
person to remember me and
i've never thought i want to stand out
as a client
that's insane like be the best he's ever
had like a sexter is so pedestrian it's
like oh every day the same thing like
one time this you want to be memorable
i don't know wait one time this girl i
want to be completely unmemorable
a lot of times i put on sunglasses and
stuff because i've already been high
yeah or i've been like you know i think
a lot of it is the allure too it's like
i'm high on cocaine we need some chicks
and it's like there's no way to get
chicks at like 3 a.m yeah if you're just
like alive on you know if you don't you
know and you're not like
in a place where there's like awake
chicks you know so it's like you have to
get you have to reach out to awake
chicks so basically
you need something some guy you need
some girls with insomnia right
yeah in the middle of the night
hooker it's just a sleep clinic they're
really just awake chicks you know that's
all
what's better awake it's not even
it's like a diner yeah
but i would say that
66 of the time or even
80 percent of the time it's been like i
probably had maybe
i would say probably i don't know five
six experiences in my life and
eighty percent of the time has been a
negative experience
oh wow what was that one good time
because if we're talking 80 five times
um that's
i think one time the lady was just
really really nice okay
but other times yeah it's like a lady
you know one time a lady had a gun a guy
with a gun hanging out outside and it
was like i can't i can't even get an
erection like if there's like
you know like broken glass around
so if
oh for sure
dude if i'm hard
and somebody's broken glass in the
vicinity if the neighbors are having a
party and somebody chips a wine glass
like a damn meat ghost my dick is gone
okay
so it's over and the girl that was nice
did she was she just like nice
afterwards and it was like she was just
nice she was just nice she just seemed
like a nice gal yeah um
and i'm sure they're so relieved when
it's i mean i don't know what you're
like in the circumstance but you seem
you're you seem like a nice guy like
even in that state of mind they're
probably relieved
you're not going to murder them i mean
every guy is a gamble there's so much
fear in all that moment yeah unless
you're like with your but like we had
i feel like i'm doing all the talking no
no this is fascinating no no i want to
know so you you've you've gone in with
other guys on it before and you had like
two or one show up well i used to live
with a family member that was an exotic
dancer you know
and not exotic like joe like uh
like in a cage or something you know
with like mange or something you know
just
like a stripper dancer
lady of the you know
burleigh you know burlesque but with
tits and is stripper a bad
word i mean it
this is not yeah exotic dancer though
yeah
yeah i mean
look she had an llc and everything so it
was like have you ever seen her perform
i mean she's a family member no but we
looked similar and every now and then
there would be like a businessman that
would look at me in a strange way and i
would be like
and i would know that flash like you're
talking about that flash of truth and it
would just hit me like this guy's having
some
you know he's a familiar have i met you
before i'd be like
no you haven't get back to your wife
you know i'd say [ __ ] like that under my
breath
but um were you sad when you found out
your family member was stan was it
something that was like oh we see this
for her or was it like you got you can't
do this
no because i think i i think she kind of
like took it in like an empowering type
of way i mean i know there was probably
some behind this you know once i later
got older and realized like oh we're
messed up and that's why
you know
you know people are showing their body
or we're out we're out here that you
know desperate for some type of
attention yeah
i've always kind of felt like
stand up to me is emotional
yes that's what i feel like the things i
talk about the things i say like have
are so
they're like you know they're full fully
like what you know some strippers only
do topless what's it called when they're
like yeah i i feel like i think yeah
like i expose myself like [ __ ]
everything like i feel like i sometimes
do that you know metaphorically in a way
that's like who could no one's gonna
love me because i talk like this or like
yeah if it gets back to someone that
i've done this or said this thing
to a family member of
my boyfriend or like they'd be ashamed
and sometimes you i yeah i feel that way
i feel like ugh why did i do that that
was
gross and then other ways it's like oh
it's really freeing and it's like
[ __ ]
what anyone thinks i don't know i
struggle with it
but i'm sure you know
at least i can like age into this but
not even like as i get older i'm like
stop talking about
sex and all the things that were like a
little bit cuter when you were younger
but it's like i st
i'm not i don't think i'm i'm not doing
it to like
i'm not doing it so people like think
i'm hot or to like turn men on that's
never been like my goal and if it does
i'm always like oh god like i'm
i don't like that energy around i don't
like when guys come up at meet and
greets and they're like
hey
uh hey uh uh can you roast should you
roast me like i it first of all we that
that guy and i would never be compatible
because that's the guy that like wants
me to
stomp on his balls with a stiletto heel
or something you know what i mean like
that's a guy that likes to get like a
guy that wants to be roasted is like
horny for it
it's not going to work but they like
some guys do get horny for it but do
they oh yeah
there are some guys that like love to be
like the fact that they watch my roasts
and you can tell they show up being like
they sit in the front row just like so
eager like please please tell me i have
a small [ __ ] dick yeah well they like
it but then
why what do they want out of that
um they wanna what they maybe don't want
they
they maybe want somebody to very popular
why they want that yeah i mean like
that's a that's a huge
genre of porn of just like
being dominated and being told like yeah
you little [ __ ] [ __ ] look at your
[ __ ] stupid dick and like just
yelling at them but i don't like your
dick never went to school boy
you know
get your dick back out there at work
yeah i don't i relate to like i like the
i like the other side like i enjoy i
don't like being
made fun of in bed or sexually or
called like you're an ugly like anything
mean about me but i like being dominated
or being
told like um just feeling like powerless
a little bit so i get i get what these
guys want but i that's not
it's the opposite i'm the opposite on
stage of what i would want in a
relationship so anyone that's like i'm
really horny for like i watch her stand
up and i'm just like god she's so
[ __ ] hot i'm just like it would never
work between us but you've been i'm sure
you've uh
hooked up with some fans though huh no
never uh-uh no no never i really haven't
i just don't i'm not
i just feel like i
it's not that i'm not honest up there
and it's not exactly what i want to say
and what i want to do but i feel like in
a relationship i just want to be or in a
sexual scenario
i don't want to be in control i don't
want to be in a position of power i
don't want to be the one talking i want
to be like a quiet whole wow like i just
don't want to
that's i do that too i feel like because
stand up is all about control we write
our own stuff we're the only ones on
stage we get we have we decide what we
write we we're the only ones talking we
overpower anyone we don't have a band
there's no collaboration it's a control
thing and i think that yeah
i think in sex or in a lot of ways we
just look for ways to get out of control
because we're like tired of being in
control so that's the last place where i
want any control i don't want to think
about anything it's so nice yeah to not
that's the one time where it's like even
during massages that i pay for i feel
like
still a pressure to like
respond to them or like stay awake or
talk to them or like
not fall asleep
there's always pressure and i feel like
in sex if you're really
connected with someone and like have
that dynamic you can i can really like
disappear and not it's almost like
disappearing in a way that's probably
not healthy because you're like trying
to get out of who you are and like not
be in the room yeah but i think that's
so fun to be able to do that and not be
like
it to get high
from sex without drugs or whatever
that's i mean if i'm not smoking weed
and i i don't drink anymore but i go in
and out of smoking weed um
that's like that's my high and then i
want to do that i mean i just like
[ __ ] switch things i mean so you're
saying like okay so you're saying like
during so you like being kind of uh
you're submissive okay yes so then
here's what i think is interesting is i
think there's different reasons why men
and women then get into probably comedy
for whim for men
i think the original thing is i want to
be seen by women i want to be validated
you know i want you know sarah to look
at me or i want angelica to you know see
me and think oh there's something about
him yeah and it works
so for women then what is that because
if y'all aren't out there trying to trap
oh man i'm trying to get seen but i'm
trying to get seen and and heard
and
um so for wisdom it's a more of a
business almost sense i think it's about
i think it's about wanting to be heard
and feeling like i just felt like
growing up if i kind of like really pull
it apart and figure out why i do it i
think that's like i felt like a weird
kid i never got to the things i would
say would always make people go like ew
like what and like look at each other
concerned want to get me help so i just
learned to like not talk and also i
thought that if i ever talked
um boys would call me ugly so if i ever
said something
it would make it would make people look
at me and remember that i existed and
then they would call me ugly and then
that's like i mean because it happened a
couple times enough where it was like
okay i learned my lesson like do not
talk because the boys that are like
just crazy enough yeah just and the boys
that liked me honestly i look back and
i'm like they were the ones that called
me ellen when ellen was like had just
come out and was gay did you seem like a
gay woman yeah because i didn't like a
lot of gay looking stuff no i just
didn't like boys i did i liked boys but
i didn't want to talk to them i didn't
want to kiss them i didn't want to date
i mean i wanted to but i didn't know how
and so i just never had boyfriends and
so i think that they were just like
nikki's gay and so they called me ellen
and um and then like you know just but
were you doing hand jobs and stuff were
you proving yourself no dude i didn't do
anything wow so you weren't proving that
you weren't gay
no i mean i didn't i i definitely didn't
think i was because i love jonathan
taylor thomas like a lot and he's almost
a woman
you're not wrong zac after you two i
mean they're a handsome guy but they're
you know no when i get to that you know
zac efron was my fir like i would say my
most recent that i was just like jesus
christ and i looked at his face one day
i'm like he has a woman's face
like he's a really pretty guy so i don't
know like i definitely somewhere on the
spectrum but no i like dudes and i but i
was too scared of them because i just i
thought i would be bad at things that's
why i'm so interested in like how do you
make a first move like how do you go
from library to sex because to me even
now i'm like
how if you're not drunk
how do you make a first move how do you
go from like we
are just people talking to we are gonna
put ourselves inside each other is just
so wild to me and i was just too scared
i couldn't couldn't do it i didn't kiss
a boy until i was
um 17. wow really yeah and it was just
because my friend literally like brought
this guy in the room and was like you're
making out with him and like sat him
down and was like you two go and i was
like thank you someone's making me do
something so i feel like in sex when i'm
submissive or like in that kind of role
and someone's making me do stuff or you
know
with cons like my consent like they're
safe words and stuff but if someone's
making me do something
i can do anything i'll i'll do anything
because i'm a people pleaser and it's
not my fault if i do this wrong well i
didn't even want to you made me do it
if i
am not good at this thing well you said
i had to it's like i'm why should i be
good at this it's the first time i'm
doing it you're making me do this thing
so i haven't out oh so it's almost like
you you like you kind of play that uh
damned linda strat or this yeah
yeah a little bit tied up and just like
i can't i mean i used to have a joke
about it but i liked being tied up a lot
of times because i wouldn't have to do
anything to the guy and not because i
was like lazy but because
i didn't want to like be bad at things i
just always thought i just had two i
would overhear boys and hear them talk
about girls and be like oh you know she
gave me like she
scraped my dick with her tea too much
teeth or like there's always that kind
of stuff when you were young and it
would ruin that threw up on my day
scared yeah if you're a high school
student out there boys she left freckles
on my dick somebody said that one time
that is the worst that's the way you
will not get [ __ ] is if you talk around
girls that you want to [ __ ] about girls
that you have slept with and you
disparage them you might think it
because i i get the psychology of guys
if you like a girl you talk badly about
other girls so that this girl feels like
like oh i don't like her i like you but
girls for me at least i would hear that
and say he's going to do that to me so
i'm not ever going to touch this guy
because i don't want to be the girl that
gets made fun of behind
my back
i remember my buddy one time got a uh
the first bj in our area right i mean
people were [ __ ] fired up wait what
is that we're talking some your area
seventh grade seventh grade yeah yeah
yeah that was around the same time so he
got bj'd up and everybody was [ __ ]
you could hear people cheering in the
damn distance it was uh you know you
could hear his ancestors
lightened up yeah you could see i mean
betsy ross just put another star on the
flag you know like
people were excited right yeah so then
it the story came out that people
started hearing about it yeah right and
then the gal's parents heard about it
so then the gal and her parents went
over the parents called my buddy's
parents oh my god and this poor girl
because they were real pretty religious
and so they said well we're going to
come over here and talk about this if
people's bj and and if our child's bj
and we're going to come over there and
talk about it
so they drove over and my buddy was like
dude i i remember talking to him on the
phone before he's like i have to go sit
in there oh my gosh and they want us to
tell them everything that happened no
here's the crazy part
here's the craziest part
they made them
not like physically show them like with
their sexual parts but like okay show us
how you were
show us how you were so then the gal is
because my buddy let me put the phone on
and let it be just under the table in
there and when the meeting was going on
my god
so because i think the parents wanted to
make sure that everything was and there
was nothing like force that happened
okay so they're having it basically
reenactment right then here's the crazy
part
they send the kids out of the room so
that they can talk about it
and i don't remember exactly but i swear
my buddy give him another one
while they were talking about it man
that's when you gotta [ __ ] beat that
hammer son i mean the seventh grade i
remember the first girl that gave a
blood eighth grade the first girl and it
was just like it was out i couldn't
believe off the world your mouth on a
penis like i've all the chicks were like
oh and all the guys were like
yeah i mean it was so titillating i mean
i wanted to know everything about it but
i was like god damn it i haven't even
kissed a boy i'm years away from kissing
a guy a friend of mine just put i
remember sobbing the first time one of
my close friends sucked a penis i cried
so hard because i knew that i would have
to do it someday
and i also knew that i lost her like we
don't have anything in common now if you
can do that it was like my friends who
rode roller coasters i wanted to so bad
but i was too scared i just couldn't do
it i and i would just sit at six flags
and sit on the bench janet's gone yeah
yep that's how i felt she's gone and i
lost her i really cried like i mourned
it because i just felt like i'm getting
left behind and i did like all my
friends got boyfriends were like hooking
up getting their [ __ ] eaten and i
just had never even kissed a boy and i
would be like just but i knew everything
i would ask every detail so by the time
i did that stuff i knew exactly what to
do
i was not i was not nervous by the time
that i got i got to the place where i
was like the librarian of it kind of it
seems like you were kind of the pro at
that point you were yeah yes i knew
everything and i didn't get my period
till super late and i was by the time i
got my period all my i knew everything
about because my friends i would ask
every detail i put in a tampon like i
was like
an old grizzled ant like it was like
i've been doing it for years and you as
a girl you don't start with tampons you
start with like pads or like toilet
paper and you're like am i dying why am
i bleeding but i was just like oh i know
what to do here because i just knew
because i had asked so many questions
and i think that's what i still have is
that like curiosity about sex like it
even though i have it and now i'm in
that world i still am just like
i just want to know every detail i just
think it's fascinating like how we get
from being clothed to unclothed and like
licking each other's privates it's just
so weird yeah you got to get you
you got to get stupid like you
that's what horniness does it makes you
kind of dumb
well yeah when you think about that
horniness is built into you i mean when
you're a child and it starts to go off
in you
i mean it's basically like you're
sitting there just pretending that
you're not just full of fireworks all
the time you know you know what the
feeling was because i didn't know what
it was i was just like oh yeah i
remember being horny bro were you sh did
and i'm by by i don't know what it was i
didn't know to have shame about it
like i didn't know that this was a
feeling like i would just watch
dave matthews storytellers on vh1 and
like rock back and forth on my heel and
not really not like sweating and getting
like real horned up and do it in front
of my parents like i wouldn't even know
that what i was feeling i was so out of
touch
with like what that was
do you remember like the first time you
started getting
the buzz i remember my buddy william
would like drag his body across the
carpet with like front down you know
with the front side down and just
he would literally just like in the
military crawl all around the [ __ ]
house getting hard you know
and uh
i mean you know yeah you'd see like we'd
be watching an episode of like little
house in the prairie and like you know
they get in there swimming you know long
johns and damn there goes william just
damn elbow crawling bro he'd be off
he'd do two laps through the kitchen
bruh before he come back lieutenant
danning he just couldn't handle it he's
just keeping his front just
flush on the carpet you know
yeah i mean well it's interesting that
that so that happens inside of us so
that's a thing that says hey we want to
have sex we want to procreate we and and
nature wants it to happen kind of
sometime after that probably nature yes
yes i'm saying so that's nature's plan
you know is
people doing sex when they're probably
16 or something or 14 you know oh yeah
that's nature's plan sure
so then we come in with our human plan
and we say well these are some of our
rules and stuff and it's like okay well
that's when a lot of like uh
illegalities happen you know yeah and
sex issues and stuff like that you know
um but i feel like i remember it i
remember yeah somebody blew you know
oh then i remember i ended up getting a
bj one time first one
yeah
and we met out or i remember we were
meeting in the woods it was at a party
yeah it's like it's gonna meet in the
woods
and louisiana has wood woods it's not i
mean there's like spiders there's like
dragons
there's like dead [ __ ] out there
probably yeah you know there's pirate
ships there's a lot in there so you meet
in the woods but we met in the woods and
it was getting damp like we were meeting
it was getting real um
muddy
so i mean i remember being oh we were
slogging and dude and then i remember it
getting even a little bit more like
almost like probably a couple inches of
water oh my god where are we meeting am
i going kind of the wrong way to me
so i'm like
you know i'm like out and damn
you know i'm almost in south carolina
you know i'm saying like i really
you know i'm in the backdrop of where
the crawdads sing you know i'm saying
it's really like i'm passing boats like
and you don't have phones how do you
know where to meet this girl dude i was
just following the possibility
that i was going to get a bj it happened
i would still be walking
if the possibility
had never left my head
and so i finally we finally got to each
other and by that point i mean i had
like locus on me i had like
i was a damn ecosystem you know like i
was certainly uh i wasn't doing great
you know there was like scientists
texting me there was like oh my god you
know it was really hot it was bad you
know
it
oh there was moss growing on the north
side of me like i had barely made it to
i was three years older when i got to
her when i finally got there it was
illegal
for her to give me the [ __ ] oh my god
how long it took man was it awesome was
it like as good as you had thought it
would be
because i mean i'm guessing this girl is
like a younger like you're on the
younger side of things it's probably one
of her first two maybe you know uh maybe
she doesn't know what she's doing but
was it just so great
well by that point other kids are coming
looking for us you know oh okay by that
point by the time we finally met it
there were other kids yelling and yeah
because you were missing for hours oh
this crazy party
oh it was crazy there was a lantern i
remember i'm like somebody had a little
lantern out here
there was a lantern there was beagles oh
there were two beagles
you know
uh
it was getting and it was getting really
really bad you know and so we had to
shut it down right okay
and then
another time
um
so then we rebooked it for a couple of
weeks later when someone else had a
party yeah you know
so
oh you knew it was gonna be a [ __ ]
yeah i knew it because she had maybe
done it before yeah and she was like the
one that you knew to go to for that kind
of thing but i also liked her though oh
yeah that's sweet so i really really
liked her and i think i was also there
was embarrassment because she'd done
some [ __ ]
yes you know so you thought
did you i like her but i'm afraid of
what other people will think if i like
her oh yeah cuz she's a [ __ ] well i
don't know if she's a [ __ ] but she's
done some [ __ ] right i was saying
[ __ ] isn't like people like i think
she's and then what does that mean and
then you can't
yeah are you one of these guys that um
if you're dating someone you don't want
to know about their history you don't
want to you kind of want to convince
yourself
uh you kind of want to be in denial of
their past even though you know like you
just don't want to know about it
he hasn't i don't care anymore oh that's
good because it's like
unless they were like work uh yeah i
don't think i care really i think it's
more now about can what the connection
is you know yeah um
but then i remember me and this gal we
befriended somebody so we could go to
their birthday right like we kind of
like because you needed a spot right so
we ended up at this nerdy girl's
birthday right met her at the library
i'm sure
neither of us even really knew her and
we're at the party and we're kind of
using her for her guest room oh people
are trying to like just play games and
stuff and there's water balloons and
like it was really it was still like a
they were real uh
they was more premature you know
and so we were trying to get a sneak off
for this bj you know when they're doing
like pin the tail in the dunk and just
things where it's like
we gotta get this
clown yeah and time was ticking it was
getting later in the day like there was
a pony there was a pony right now god oh
my god we gotta sneak off and get this
bj in somewhere around here and uh so we
snuck off behind this tree and it was
like
they don't really have the trees wide
enough to get a bj behind them where i'm
from you know without somebody seeing
this thin birches yeah it's a lot more
what's the thickest tree in louisiana
you think zach if you pull something up
like that
because you can really get blown behind
one of these uh okay
you know
no yeah search only for thickest
that taxodium distectum huh
15.90 what is that meter that's girth
yeah
yes by girth that's uh we're talking
meters here
i assume diameter
[Music]
so
well i guess these people couldn't
afford one of those right so because
that's really wide enough almost
especially at that age in california you
got the redwoods you can [ __ ] have an
orgy behind one of those
[Laughter]
oh dude you can build a car max behind
one of them
but anyway i couldn't and the and the
kid's mom came over oh [ __ ] and was like
y'all her blow job and then i was like
i'm not you know and
then the girl felt bad when i said i'm
not oh and uh and then i felt bad
because i wasn't like it was her idea no
i wasn't she was doing it you know oh
right they're blow-dry they're
blow-topping i'm not i'm just standing
here she came up yeah she came i was
just trying to get some air
no now that she came up like my yeah
like
like my penis was just wandering around
the air okay
you can't get you said when was your
first
like you're getting man well so then we
got busted and that was a bad issue
and then um
probably about
i think it was a couple years later
a girl gave me a hand job into a um
small waterway
and uh
like a stream everything is outdoors
for you guys
yeah well yeah i think the people i knew
didn't have big indoors
yeah so it was like if there's not a lot
of room indoors you gotta so into a
small waterway you were like looking
over a small bobbling brook
no it was bit it was larger than that i
mean you could catch something out of it
all right
and so you got a hand job out of that
into the stream into the street yes he
goes back so scared you know yeah that
scared me what's because i would never
be able to get that semen back first no
really something about it but hadn't you
ejaculated before and felt the same way
or did you try to put it back in then
like
well my armor we jerked off one time and
my dad made us bury it out in the yard
no way what
yeah wait he caught you jerking off
and he's bury your semen
in the backyard
so you in your hand not even in the back
it was in the side yard
wait
that is
why why
i don't know he said that's god's and
that's where it goes oh my god
theo
pretty cool that's crazy you got
something in your pants baby that's
bugging you that's itching that's
growing
it's probably hair
it's probably hair you bushed out baby
you georgian and george w and right
there in your pants and your crotch
taking control of that body bush is
important
that's why manscaped
is sponsoring us they're here to help
they'll help you tame that bush
without hiring people that have knives
and wheat whackers
whether you're looking to go bald like
an eagle or just to need a little trim
manscaped is dedicated to helping you
level up your full body grooming
when you trim your hair down your
your package looks taller and longer put
a damn graduation cap on your wiener
it's just basic landscaping that's how
it is
if you get the performance package
purchase you get two free gifts
you get the shed travel bag and the
patented high performance reduced
chafing manscaped boxers
they have a bunch of other products on
their website as well you can check them
out
but make sure to use our code you get 20
off and free shipping with the code theo
at manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use the code theo
it's time to level up
from the amazon to the amadong
with the ultimate bushwhacking tools
whack that bush
from manscaped blue chew baby you got to
pep that weiner baby
you got to pep that weiner daddy
and that's blue chew they'll do it
blue chews tablets combat all forms of
erectile dysfunction
and can help men gain extra confidence
for when it's time to perform baby you
send your wiener off to war you gotta
peel him up
blue chews licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredients and strength for your
prescription
it's a unique online service that blue
chew offers
they have the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but it's in chewable
form you snack that baby
snack that baby and up your wiener snack
that baby
and up your wiener
that's right
you can benefit from extra confidence
it's time to visit bluechew
and guys here's a special code for you
try blue chew free
when you use our code theo at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code t-h-e-o to
receive your first month free up that
weiner baby that's a thing like there
are some guys that like i think have an
issue with coming and you should because
it like when you come it [ __ ] with your
limbic system and i mean it
it also makes you
the interesting thing i found about uh
when i was i was like reading these
books that
about like the male orgasm female orgasm
and how much it [ __ ] you up and how
i you know i just had so many
experiences where i slept with guys too
soon when i really thought that i had
waited long enough they really liked me
this was this was we're going to the
next level this was actually making us
like we're gonna be boyfriend girlfriend
after this i didn't get the word of it
but it was like this is in the bag and
then we'd have sex
and then instantly they would change and
like some they just weren't into me
anymore and they kind of
yeah and
it was about and they would sometimes
try to not come because they knew what
was coming on the other side of that
there was nothing i did it was that they
came and then i found out biologically
because we used to like live in tribes
and just have sex with everyone and no
one like not everybody i'm sure there
was some people in the tribe yeah you
skipped a couple yeah like oh a little
randall over there yeah let's leave dude
that guy's over there [ __ ] eating
chia seeds out of his belly button i
think i'm a pass on [ __ ] him you know
but we used to
i'm sure within within reason you used
to just like have sex with everyone
because you got to make a lot of babies
for the [ __ ] totally you had to get
more goods to be able to survive the
winter yeah because and babies don't
live so everyone's [ __ ] everyone so
your body when you come as a man your
subconscious like your caveman brain
whatever it is is telling you don't do
not come with this girl again like you
already got her if she's gonna get
pregnant that's the
you've already done it don't drop a
second load in this woman because that
would be a waste of your sperm
so don't that's why men afterwards have
this like
you know
flight response of like get away because
it would be a waste for you to [ __ ]
someone twice within the same like
ovulation period and that's this whole
book was about like
not
making it so like you if you want to
keep a guy interested in you just don't
let him come wow ever and they'll be
obsessed with you and there is some
truth to that i mean like even
i i feel that way in
in relationships i'm scared of come now
because i've on the other side of it
when a guy comes there even if they're
like
my partner at the time there's just a
lack of interest in me that was like
they were pawing on me before so into me
and then afterwards it's as we all feel
after we are satiated but i don't like i
don't like that to go away suddenly it
felt like oh my god then that was fake
or something sometimes i'll be like
please don't come because i want you to
like
crave me forever i always want that to
be there i hate when it goes away that's
a great point maybe that's because
because i'll say this whenever i would
ejaculate into my hand or whatever
it always felt like that wasn't supposed
to be outside that's one thing that i
always felt like yes it's like this
doesn't feel like it's just supposed to
be outside of me yeah what a because
it's a waste that was that semen is to
like make a baby and now your body has
to like make more you just like wasted
this thing that was gonna keep
you going keep the human species going
and you just blew it like your job as a
man is to make sure that goes into a
vagina that is fertile and you you
failed so there of course there would be
some kind of like disappointment or
shame
on the other side of that subconsciously
or even consciously
you just blew it out here in the back of
a school bus or behind a shonies or
something you're like
now you're just riding there on the bus
next to your scene and you're just like
all right that's interesting
because i feel the same way after i have
an orgasm but my thing is that i get sad
because
it's gonna i get sad because i want to
feel that again right now and i have to
wait now to build it up again and i'm
like it's almost like after
i i like to wait to eat until i'm really
hungry so that the food tastes better
like i love to wait i'm a pleasure to
layer and so i always after i come i'm
always just like
man
the most fun part of that whole thing
was up until it happened yeah when it
happened it feels good but really the
best part is the anticipation that's why
i love i love anticipation i love when
the when i see the waiter bringing my
food like that is that's a better
feeling to me than when i'm actually
eating it i think
i like i on christmas i notoriously as a
kid i would never open my christmas
presents i would just i would hoard them
and be like because i didn't want
christmas to be over the saddest day of
the year is december 26th yeah i might
argue the saturdays december 25th the
afternoon after christmas presents are
opened
because people are cool before that it's
like what what could be and now you know
what is and it's fine it's nintendo and
you're psyched and you're playing duck
hunt with your cousin but before that
it who knows what it could have been
wow that's interesting you know i like
to think of what if
right
and i like to know fantasy
yeah maybe that's some of the
differences right there between men and
women you like to know what i like to
know exactly what's going to go on yeah
i don't like there to be a lot of room
for i think that scares me you know if
there's like a lot of like what could
happen i think that's just some of the
difference between men and women you
know i think that's why like um you can
see a male orgasm you know it's like
yeah
yeah and women orgasm you're like maybe
yeah we don't know yes but you know it's
more like up in the air is what i'm
saying even if you go to that you know
yeah this lady said something what you
got here zachary you had a video you
wanted us to see yeah while we're on
this topic there's a utah state rep uh
is getting a lot of flack for this kind
of hot take about seaman
oh man that i
clearly don't trust women enough to make
choices to control their own body and my
response is i do trust women enough to
control when they allow a man to
ejaculate inside of them and to control
that intake of semen so that may be
inflammatory but i think as a
legislature we have the responsibility
to create a legal framework that is
friendly and supporting rights that i oh
so she's saying you can control how much
semen goes in you no you no you can't
well can um
no i mean like men are stronger than us
sorry it's like that's the bottom line
like we
all of this is about if we were as
strong as you guys this would not be an
issue like nothing it's we're the weaker
sex physically i mean some of us can
work out hard enough and there's jujitsu
to use your body strength against
yourself but like generally
we cannot fight you off if you decide in
the middle of sex to hold us down it
wouldn't take much it doesn't take much
even if we're so fast and we work out
every day a guy who doesn't work out in
a quick sprint well can catch us you
guys are
faster and more powerful so no we can't
control if you want to come in us you
can come in us
oh dang
well thanks first of all
[Music]
second of all
uh
i didn't say may you oh yeah yeah that
old bathroom trick no i'm not doing
anything like that man i never i will i
mean i will
not i will like to even go and ejaculate
in the other room you know no that's not
a bad idea because you don't associate
it with the girl and so you might still
have that in you to be like i gotta [ __ ]
her and so you might still be interested
in her that's like actually one of the
tactics they talk about
in this book i read about male orgasms
and avoiding them is like if he has to
come like don't have him not associated
with you and then he'll still like you
hmm because it's about like
some of that i think makes sense you
know but yeah sometimes i feel so bad
about all the you know just all the
ejaculate or whatever that i left in
different places and just shouldn't have
left cause you feel like it's like a
part of you you feel like it's like yeah
sometimes i'd even drive through an old
neighborhood and even
look at that spot where you buried it to
see if the tree grew grew oh i didn't
think about that a tree where you could
maybe get a [ __ ] behind it someday oh
yeah i'm freaking strong enough
to hide two kids
all checking out theo your dad made you
bury your semen when he caught you the
first time you got caught
masturbating you had to take your semen
and bury it in the yard like of course
you have issues with like a j like guard
feeling like
but yeah i mean
and it goes it spreads from there [ __ ]
i mean like everything we do is because
of something that happened in our
childhood like i know it was a lesson we
learned from our parents who were just
like doing their best which wasn't
really that great oh i saw one time it
reminds me actually there was this
uh
this kind of ratchet chick you know i
was into like real ratchet kind of
chicks for a while nice huh i don't know
i just liked it you know
and um
she had earrings like on her like on the
sides of her
wait on her labia yeah
like hoops yeah wow okay
it was cool never heard of that i've
never i didn't know it could even
because you always think of like [ __ ]
piercings which seems really painful but
yeah that makes sense just like labia
like
this lady was really she was pretty
ratchet and she had earrings on her
[ __ ] yeah yeah and it was like
definitely
like you could see it like eating
popcorn at a ball game like front row at
an nba game you know what i'm saying
like no i don't know what you're saying
but
like it was definitely uh i mean it
looked like it had like
i don't know are you do you do you i've
talked a lot about this before and and i
am always curious i don't care anymore
about i used to be very paranoid about
like
what if the guy thinks my vagina is ugly
like if it's not like perfectly like
tight and just like a little line like
do you care about that stuff when you
are there vaginas that you're just like
like or is it just like i'm horny this
is fine whatever like
because
yeah i just wanna i feel like men
men and women have so much insecurity
about our genitals you guys more so size
us is us is also size but it's like
if it's
we just don't know what other women are
are have down there
and so we we are scared ours is just
grotesque compared to it or at least i'm
speaking for myself
the only one that i you know the only
time i've really had some bad experience
with some vagina was um
if you know if it really has if it if
somebody has an ill vagina yeah or a
sick vagina or like somebody but you
know has a
you know if there's that that that's a
tough thing you know yeah and i think it
can even be the same for men if some
men's wiener stink you know it's like
gingivitis like they don't even know
it's like a chronic thing it's a
bacterial thing that's it yes and i'll
even send a friendly text sometimes like
hey this isn't to be rude or anything
yeah i love hanging out with you
but you know but this i mean that the
tough thing was that one yeah the girl
with that little you know just that damn
yeah
you know the little drummer girl or
whatever yeah yeah
yeah when she broke out that little
barrampa bomb dude that little drummer
girl
that [ __ ] that was that was too hectic
man i wanted to literally
you know i don't know a lot of this
stuff's interesting man how's your
vagina doing how are you doing are you
are you a lie are you dating are you
yeah i have a boyfriend oh good yeah i'm
back uh a guy dated for
like
man we were together three years off and
on and then um we took a five-year break
and then we've been dated we dated for
like about a
nine months and then we made it official
i think like four months ago
but like we went to
we went to couples therapy before we
were even a couple cause i was like i
just don't want to do this again because
we always just break up and get together
it's just the point where our families
are just like not taking us seriously
and so right we're we're we're doing it
you're like guns and roses almost
yeah i don't like do you think
you were getting back together it never
happened yes an appetite for destruction
you know
yeah what about you
um what's going on
uh i'm actually taking a little bit i'm
not dating trying not to date for 30
days oh that's nice no no not uh do any
dating for 30 days are you on apps and
stuff like that
how were you dating before dm slides
um after shows
meeting some women occasionally meeting
women in real time
you know
yeah but i think it's just i i think
i've had this kind of like
i didn't realize that i've had this kind
of software kind of running like
i need to have some interaction with a
woman right like um
whether it be a tech text exchange or a
porno or watching a pornography or
watching a um
even a drawing of [ __ ]
yeah anything like that any i need to
have some interaction of woman you know
buying a wig or something looking at it
you know different kind of stuff where
you could be like
you know i need to have some interaction
of woman that where it's like the
possibility of a connection of intimacy
whether it be just just a female
interaction yeah like what could be
something yeah yeah because i'll notice
like uh
like i'll sit at home no drinking and
stuff like that you know so
i've been
i think i have almost like 90 days sober
right now so congrats thanks pretty cool
damn and i i'm realizing and i'm not
saying i'm not that i'm not going to
stay in this program but i realize when
i sit there or
i realize also when i just sit there
a lot of alcoholics they think i need a
drink i need i want something to drink
i realize for me
i want to interact with a female
just to know that a female will interact
yes yes that's it
it doesn't have to be about sex it
doesn't even but i need there's that's
my drink yeah
oh yeah so it's like i realize
oh that's my drink that's my alcohol is
that is some sort of validation or
acceptance
um
from a woman setting up a date uh
saying hey i'll you know uh or calling a
girl that i care about even you know
just anything it's any other it could be
anything on the spectrum but not a go
not a platonic it's a like romantic
interest yeah romantic but even
sometimes platonic can be part of it
because it'll like it depends on what
need i have at that moment if i have a
need where it's like
um a sexual need then i'll just do a
date with a girl who wants to say who's
looking for to do sex if or i'll do
pornography if it's i just want to flirt
then i'll just flirt if it's that i want
to talk to someone i care about or who
cares about me i'll do that but it's
like i notice i kind of
and a lot of it's normal behavior yeah
but it's not normal when it's like um
the second i start to feel a little bit
of uncomfort that's the thing that i do
to solve this every way the second
something will like but bef you know
before when i was single like the second
one would drop off instantly need to
replace it with another oh this guy's
not writing me back find another one
make sure you're still [ __ ] making
sure you're still
validated honestly like that someone
wants to stick their dick in you even
though like i could post a picture and
someone would write some disgusting
thing that would make me feel that way
but you want it to be someone who you
would maybe entertain the idea of doing
that but it's i i know that itch
where you just
just sometimes um just going on the apps
and matching with someone you get that
hit of dopamine
of just like a connection just seeing
the connection i don't even need to talk
to them like okay that guy would that
guy would and i'm a [ __ ] i'm terrified
of having sex with people and meeting up
with people i oh i was just going a lot
of people would [ __ ] you you know that
right but and but for some reason i need
i don't know but i still crave that i
mean and yeah also
you you start to age and you go oh i
feel it's slipping away it's not it it's
not as
um
it's not as apparent anymore and then
you start to feel it go away and then
you're like well i'm eventually gonna
get old enough where i open i really
hope no one wants to [ __ ] me i don't
want to be
90 and having people like that'll be
your last you stop for me
you know what i mean like that you're
vulnerable you're 90. it reverses you no
you don't want anyone being sexual like
i don't want to sexualize when i'm 90.
it's like you're a baby again that's why
we don't i don't want anyone to want to
[ __ ] me because i can't fight you off
i'm like a fragile old woman so you want
to be like not sexual but that's scary
to me is like i'm a dying battery of
hotness everyone is a dying battery of
fuckability and like you can plug
yourself into little like portable
chargers
right here and there but those are gonna
die too and you're gonna you're
eventually gonna have to age that's
scary to me oh that's been a very scary
thing for me even in the past few years
just getting older and feeling like um
oh yeah first of all like i have to be
an adult too i got to do adult stuff you
know taxes and stamps
yeah and looking people in the eye when
you talk to them oh god yeah is that
hard for you i think i think all of that
kind all that kind of stuff has always
been a little tough for me you know
but um yeah i have the new thing of like
on an airplane i really like to like
curl up in a ball like on the window and
i put my foot up on the thing and i
don't i make sure not to disturb anyone
and i put a sleep mask on and i have
like a
you know jacket over my head and i'm
just like i'm 38. like this is not oh
this is not that's an
it's a child's thing to do right this is
not okay like we're i still want to
behave like a little like a child like
the eye contact thing like sometimes
i just don't want to make eye contact
with
people and and i go that's a thing i did
when i was 12 when i was scared to look
an adult in the eye like why am i still
doing this yeah yeah i think it's all
those ghosts of being a child you know
that's all we all become is just the
haunted house for ghosts of
of our youth oh yeah i'm [ __ ] so
stuck
are you that's like every time i talk to
my therapist about like my fears about
you i just have fears of like boys being
mean to me and being like if i reject a
guy they'll be like well i didn't even
want to [ __ ] you anyway you're old and
disgusting like they'll say the meanest
thing back which we know guys that do
that like the season of fboy island
that's my biggest fear for these girls
that like these three girls sign up for
the show and then on and what is on
their kids [ __ ] each other by the
beach yeah man that's kind of like it's
it's
13 boys like real sexy and 13 nice guys
so 13 guys that are like looking for
love and 13 guys that are like
there just to like get the money because
if you get chosen then you get money you
also get the girl but then if you're an
f boy and uh and so you're there to like
trick girls but the girls don't know who
is who but my biggest fear was like
these girls are gonna eliminate an f-boy
who's been pretending to be nice the
whole time and then when they do the
guy's gonna be like i didn't even think
any of you were hot anyway [ __ ] this i
can go get you're all [ __ ] sixes and
that was my biggest fear and these girls
are just so hot that they
they're just like and they have
confidence like and they're 10 years
younger than me so i just i just assume
anyone 10 years younger me has less
confidence than me i've like worked hard
to have the
amount of confidence i have which isn't
much but they don't care at all these
guys are so they will say the mean of
[ __ ] and they still like them and no
they still they're just like bye whereas
i would be like
he just said the thing that i've always
thought about myself like that's why i
will not read youtube comments on this
video i will not i only read instagram
comments on my own stuff because it
tends to be nicer but i don't read
twitter anymore i don't read youtube
comments because i'm so scared a man is
gonna call me
old like that's my new fear it that's
only in the past like five years
that happens to everybody though it
happens yes oh yeah but how do you feel
when someone calls you out for the thing
that like you think maybe no one's
noticed yet looks wise does it bother
you yeah i mean it has to but does it
does it like land you in a like i get
super depressed yeah i think it kind of
hurts my feelings i think or it like
enforces fears that i have probably yeah
um
i don't know i mean the things that i
get probably most uncomfortable about
probably my hair you know that's crazy
because it's so good i feel is that
interesting
yeah i think it's so i guess
you have a hairline
every man i know all they talk about his
hair
you did yeah
wait it hasn't gone in yet oh well it's
just your own hair from the back yeah oh
my god it's so good and it hasn't grown
in no i mean you you're i know maybe you
put work into it but it's it's paid off
it looks good oh thanks yeah yeah
things like that i get nervous about i
guess yes i mean i think being funny i
think the tough thing for me is like
i went through like some pretty severe
burnout a few years ago and i kept
working
and i didn't know that i was supposed to
stop and my career was just kind of
getting good
and i'd worked so hard
and i didn't know what to do
and i didn't really have um
you know you talk to people and they're
like you got to strike all the irons all
this kind of stuff you know yeah and um
and i'd always had a good work ethic and
so it was just like oh you just keep
working you know saying no to stuff so
hard it was hard and i loved you gave me
when we talked to each other about doing
this
i loved
i mean we don't have to talk about you
saying like hey just let me know if
you're doing another podcast so i can
time it and i was like
oh yes i don't have to do any po like
i'm doing theo's podcast i don't have to
accept any other podcast because i'm
doing theo's podcast it's a reason to
like
you gave me a reason to not have to do
because if i come to town i'll just say
yes to [ __ ] everything because i
gotta just strike by the i'm only here
for a couple days i love
you gave you essentially tied me up and
i was like oh i guess i can't give you a
hand job i'm tied up like it's it's just
such a great it's free
i need boundaries yes yeah we need
boundaries so how do you say no to
things now well i it's sometimes it's
tough you know a friend is asking to be
in his movie next month and i'm thinking
about it but then i just got off you
know i've been touring for like 16 years
and i just finally stopped don't you
love when people are like so
what's this
how long is this tour going and you go
the rest of my life i just name it a
different thing every year but it never
stops maybe i'll take a week off to go
film something but we don't stop
so you took
well i just finally i you know i just
said i don't i don't want to keep adding
dates you know i had a huge date in
vegas they were it was the most i was
ever going to get paid for a show
and i said i'm just i'm not doing it
i said i just
i can't
keep go
because here's the thing if i'm not
feeling great when i keep putting myself
out there it's the same reason
well then i catch on it's like
it's like i'm just using my sets like
yeah you're like
raping yourself kind of like my my
wellness is like you know god gave me
these gifts to be able to feel
comfortable and be humorous and like
instead it's like
you know it's like whenever you got to
the bottom of a bowl of a weed and some
kid would keep smoking just like the
dirty glass at the bottom like ernie
quit yeah [ __ ] hitting this [ __ ] dog
that shit's been empty for a month dawg
get a job though i mean i do that with
weed when i get like every six months
when i have to quit yeah when i find
myself like smoking resin and that's
what i was doing i was just smoking just
to [ __ ] resin myself yes yeah i do
that all the time too with stand up and
then you're you're bad because you're
tired on stage you resent that you have
to do it you're all you're thinking
about is when you don't have to do this
anymore and what you're gonna do
afterwards
and and then you're the audience some
they know they know that and then yeah
maybe you might make the most money
you've ever made on that one gig but
they won't come see you again because
they go i just paid so much and this was
not not that great yeah and so i'm
trying to like i'm just trying to make
gigs fun because i know that if i went
to go see my like taylor swift if i if i
had in the back of my head that she
didn't want to be there at all even one
percent was like not feeling it i
wouldn't want to go i want my performers
to like have fun that's why i do not go
i don't like going to see plays
because i feel like i would be so bored
doing the same thing over and over that
i can't imagine they're having fun
like maybe on opening night but like on
like a long like broadway when they're
doing months and months i'm like they
can't change it up at least for
stand-ups or for like musicians they can
change up the set but a play i'm just
like oh god i i project that and now i
know from talking to actors that they're
like no i like doing the same thing
every night and it does change for me
but for some reason i project like uh
every night the same thing yeah totally
autopilot
well yeah i can't enjoy it well i think
and also uh
it's a reason why you know i do this
other podcast king and the sting and
it's one of the reasons why i have to
take breaks from that it's why i started
having guests on here more instead of
just doing solo because i was just
getting burnt out i didn't want to put
my not best self out there
and then also i want to be able to have
the energy for the shows that's the part
i like the best getting to meet people
after so it's like
you know it's just like i had to monitor
like
it's just been tough and i didn't
realize i thought like oh you just keep
going people want to see you i was a
people pleaser like i wanted
it's the same as like being at the lunch
table when you're a kid and you like get
your buddies to laugh you're like oh i
just want that
you know this just keeps getting bigger
well that's all we ever wanted and now
people like actually like us and want to
come like how could you say no to that
and also the meet and greets like i love
meeting fans and at this point it's like
when you do meet and greets it's not
just like random people that just came
to the club to see you like they're
actually people that like you and like
have good boundaries like i like my fans
now but sometimes i'm like you gotta
understand i can't do it i want to meet
you guys but it's just it's too
exhausting and
you should i wouldn't want to meet
someone who didn't have the energy i
would never want to put out someone that
i was a fan of if they didn't want to do
it right like i i and it makes me mad
when they're like you cancelled the meet
and greet i'm like do you want to meet
me when i'm tired and i don't want to
meet you is that don't you wish i would
cancel that i'll give you your money
back and i'll love to meet you another
time but why would you want me to do
something i don't want to do yeah
but it's hard because i do want to do it
sometimes i'm just like god can i just
go to a town and do meet and greets yeah
because a show and a meet and greet is
and then do a two show night that's four
shows i know it's a lot of energy well
that's a weird thing it just becomes
well it just it's a lot of like putting
yourself out there
you know
and it even goes back to what we're
talking about in the beginning it's like
how much of me
i got
yeah i just kept putting myself out
there until it wasn't even about
whatever i had i know i quit feeling
like myself a couple years ago i'm just
starting to get moments where i feel
like myself again i'm good but um yeah
it's you it's just fear you know a lot
of fear and you don't want to let people
down that's another thing being a
disappointment and being and being
forgotten you think oh if i don't take
the show
you know
your agents will be let down and then
the people will be let down and you
might be forgotten and someone else is
gonna be doing stand up that night and
they're gonna get this much better than
you because they had a one more gym
session because it's like going to the
doing stand-ups like going to the gym so
not doing sets every [ __ ] night which
is why i moved to st louis because
it's not like a comedy town so i'm not
like there's not places i'm dying
there's not great place there's clubs
there but it's a little bit a far drive
i move there to get away from the
pressure of doing stand up every [ __ ]
night because i come here i'm here for
five days and i have like five sets
every night because i can't turn them
down
because
you know i don't i i because it's a gym
session because it's a like i i'm gonna
get better and i can't stand passing up
an opportunity to get better and to be
loved by strangers
[Laughter]
yeah i feel you man it's that quiet hole
you know yeah and then feeling like oh
well they don't really know me even
though i'm so honest i mean you're so
honest too like the fact that you can
even say like oh i've gotten an escort
this many times it's like that kind of
stuff people don't talk about and they
rely on us
to talk about it so that they can go oh
maybe i'm not a bad person because i've
got an escort okay theo has two
like that [ __ ] is important for us to
share but there's some times where i'm
like man pull it back a little bit no
one
people don't need to know this and you
have to i
there are very few things that i keep
private but i have a couple now but
before i was just like anything i'll say
anything and i don't even know if those
things that i've deemed like private if
there's not a time where i'd be like
this is just too good not to share yeah
this podcast isn't going well let me
just
toss this one out this gem
oh yeah
you know like i had a hooker one time an
escort you know or a bit you know i
think i don't know her we should bring
that back she might have an s corp
actually too i have no idea what her
business abilities were but she um
came over and just made me ended up
making like a carrot soup at my house oh
yum
that's
naked uh i don't know she was in um
i wasn't attracted when she got there
and i was doing drugs and everything i
remember i had on [ __ ]
like this headdress kind of thing
somebody admit like this i've been to
this tribal i did a casino show and they
made me a headdress yeah so i had that
[ __ ] on dude i was geeked up out of my
brain bro you know what i'm saying so
she made a carrot soup she just saw a
cuisinart and some carrots and
yeah and she thought you she wanted to
take care of you she's like yeah you got
an hour you don't seem like you're doing
well i was like how can you tell indoor
native american
giving you that clue over here
was that the one good experience the one
nice one what's giving you that clue the
headdress and the bloody nose
theo i'm so glad you're 90 days and she
made the uh but none of that was even
those are just kind of some of those
times are kind of fun times yeah you
know i mean they're great stories thank
god for all that stuff yeah that's true
and now somebody ruined the cocaine you
can't even do it oh no you can't
that is a man i never got into cocaine
but that that's gotta suck if some
you know i'm into weed i'm into like oh
i'm sure there's party that still wants
to [ __ ] risk it because that's
another thing about it it's like
oh you don't think i'm willing to
[ __ ] risk it all yeah i mean fentanyl
is basically you know it's really the uh
it's the alex trebek of [ __ ] dope you
know
it's just how it's like you know it's
like saying this is the fight do you
want to put it all on the line how are
you know it's a pat sajak of drugs or
whatever it's like are you willing to
risk it all you know it's suicidal it's
it's like it's russian way to look at it
yeah it is i mean but i know what you're
saying man like i
i have the whole show with the lord well
listen like sometimes i like i have a
compulsion to cut myself like i only did
it once in my life but there's sometimes
that i just feel a certain way and i
just really want to cut myself and i
don't do it because i know that i'll
have to live with the consequence that's
not something that i can like
erase there'll be a scar
there'll be some there's i never
understand that with women i don't know
what i don't know what it is either it's
for me i the only time i cut myself was
when i got caught shoplifting and i
didn't get in trouble for it they let me
go and no one knew about it and i had to
i had to punish myself i don't know what
it was but i never had the compulsion i
didn't understand cutting i remember
lucy did it on seventh heaven and i was
like what is this and for some reason it
was just exactly what i needed and i
just went to it without even thinking
and i did it yeah and
and man i mean i have so many so many
people got themselves so it's a very
common thing and it's a v i i feel the
desire often instead now i just google
people who cut themselves to hear about
their stories and read about it because
not so i can like
watch it happening and feel like oh i'm
doing it it just i think that it just
helps to see people that feel as sad and
[ __ ] up as you do and and just know
you're not that weird and so sometimes
like it's soothing to me to just like
watch videos not of people doing it but
of people talking about it same with
suicide i mean i think that's the same
thing of like
i like i see in your eyes when you're
like sometimes i just want to [ __ ]
risk it like so what like i feel the
same way about suicide for me it's like
i think about it a lot it's my go-to
response when i'm feeling sad about
myself or about the world like i get i
just think about killing myself and it's
like literally soothing like i will just
go to bed and just like
smile thinking about the option and i'm
not gonna do it i know like i've made a
pact with myself as much as you can
never gonna do it no matter how much i
want to
but man that like just
that doesn't sound safe though nikki no
i know that's why i talk about it
because
if i don't talk about it that's when it
can get out of control but i feel like
if i'm honest about it i've never
attempted it i've never planned anything
i've never written a note like i've
honestly written a note or not no no i
mean the first step would be cleaning my
apartment and like getting my affairs in
order so that my parents wouldn't have
to like deal with that stuff and even
that is like that's really i mean i used
to have a joke about it but honestly a
lot of times my apartment's so messy the
idea of even like my mom would have to
deal with my death and have to like
clean my apartment
and like the emts would arrive and see
like look at this jesus christ she lived
like a [ __ ] hoarder like that
judgment on the other side of my death
i i would need you i would already be in
i couldn't do it if i'm killing myself
i'm killing myself in a case yeah i want
to make it like as easy right but that's
not possible and it's never going to be
easy and i will literally never
it's no it's not possible to make it
easy because you will always leave
behind people that it's it's not
emotionally easy oh yeah yeah yeah it's
never going to be no matter how much you
think people are going to be better off
take it easy bub you know sorry or
whatever yes no they're not gonna be
like all right i'm gonna take it easy
since he's dead but so many people think
like they'll be better off without me
you know like that's the thing and like
it's committing suicide is a disease
it's the end of a disease it's like you
know stage
four it's like it's a terminal illness
so no one like i don't ever blame anyone
who commits suicide because i feel like
they really don't have a choice that was
no they're trying to alleviate whatever
pain is inside of them yeah and their
pain is in them so much they're like the
only way to stop this pain is to stop
the where it lives which is inside of
myself yeah it makes sense yeah um but
it's but let's talk about something else
is that okay oh please i'm sorry to even
get on that but it i just want to say
that like
if you have thought if you have thoughts
like that out there like
seriously it's it's a part of a disease
your brain is like [ __ ]
you're not because i would get into
whenever i get into that let's let's
take a suicide any negative thought
about myself sometimes you like believe
i believe like oh this is the truth like
sometimes i don't want to take my
antidepressants because i'm like
they're lies
i really see the truth and i don't want
to feel better because this is the truth
the world is [ __ ]
climate change
i'm old no one cares about me i'm not
funny i'm not like i'm not that
interesting i no one really loves me and
i know that if i take a pill i'll i
won't feel those thoughts but sometimes
i'm like then you're just dumbing
yourself but really
i'm i have a sickness i have the flu for
my brain and i'm thinking that the flu
is like right and it's not oh that's
interesting yeah so
if that helps anyone or maybe if that
makes anyone feel worse please call
someone there's always someone that will
talk to you about how you feel
yeah i mean we yeah it's hard to tell in
every moment
like if you're helping people or hurting
them you know but that's just like
sharing the [ __ ] like as dark as it is i
think it's gotta help because whenever i
find people like talking about stuff and
i go oh their life is probably perfect
not that anyone ever thinks that my life
is perfect but
i just find that i always want to know
when peop i just want people to be more
honest about how they struggle or
insecure
um
you know i sometimes i look at girls and
i'm like project so much perfection onto
like these models and like god
they never get sad their homes are
probably so clean and perfect and
their skin is just glowy all the time
and i just am so jealous and so
resentful and then i hear that they like
hate the way they look and part of me
goes [ __ ] you [ __ ] you hate the way you
look you model but then i don't know it
then i kind of feel like it it actually
helps me because i go like
well this is just a sickness because
clearly this girl is
like she's not of the right mind so
maybe i have a little hint of that yeah
maybe i'm not seeing myself clearly
well i think that's what's really
interesting is that as much footage and
everything as we have now of ourselves
that we don't see ourselves clearly dude
somehow we've lost this huge perception
of uh
of what even the value of being human i
mean i think it almost goes back to like
we're talking about about the moment
it's like
it doesn't feel like we're enough
anymore it feels like even i thought
about this the other day it feels like
it used to feel like 20 years ago if you
died it would really mean something
and it would matter
and it would really have a like a
longevity to people and now that doesn't
really feel
it feels like people would get over it
pretty quickly and the world would move
on that's what it feels like it feels
like so much faster than it would have
even those closest to you yeah and not
even because they would want to but just
because of how whatever's happening to
us as a species you've got it jesse yeah
you got to move on and i you you do you
do not have to move on that quick if one
of us dies no you don't but like you
kind of do because what are you you're
never coming back
i if i die dude i'm writing out a
holiday inn for like seven years people
can come there whenever they want and
think about me or look at maybe i love
that leave images or something in there
people can look at them maybe leave like
a little
you know a little replica of hand with
no fingers on it you know yeah and
people can just
beat themselves with it i don't know but
but here's the crazy part i bet after
like a week nobody would even come
no for anybody
no you're right for anyone but i think
that anybody i mean i mean i just
recently went to columbine
because i just i don't know what
happened my freshman year of high school
it was
very just i was just morbidly curious i
guess about it i was f i've always been
fascinated by it i read a few books
about it and i'm like i'm i love i i
don't i hate to say i love columbine but
like the way that some women are
obsessed with murders and we go oh
they're murderistas or whatever and it's
like cute that's you that's me but for
like for columbine 9 11 a little bit
like i'm
my high school was bookended by
columbine 911 and so like but i went to
columbine and um
i it was so weird to go to this place
where this like this thing happened go
to the memorial that is on kind of right
off campus
and it's just like no one else is there
like
memorializing it like i thought there
would be like crowds but it's just like
no this is the students that go there
don't even think about that like maybe
they do but it doesn't seem like it was
like
in the air there it's like they've moved
on and i'm still like how is everyone
here like i just thought that everyone
knew that i was there to like check out
where things happened and no one cared
there was i saw a cop car and i'm like
oh they probably patrol this area so
that people don't come and like
you know and he's not
yeah he's just a cop car at a high
school like another direction
they got a new dunkin put in around the
corner yeah but people move on yeah and
i i remember one time a friend of mine
died and i was
i had too much i had a busy week
and i
i had too much going on and i remember
thinking i can't
i can't cancel this thing that i have to
be happy for and like on for
and i just put a bookmark in my feelings
because i go he's never not gonna be
dead i can do this later wow like
it doesn't need to happen now i can
literally just save this for later and i
just didn't feel anything completely
shut myself off to the sadness for a few
days
and was able to do that because i just
rationalized like i have all the time in
the world he's never coming back like
so i think that's later yeah yeah that's
what everybody everything feels like
that now but i wonder what happens as a
society if when you get all those
unprocessed feelings and all that i
don't know and i think we're just
learning too you know and also we store
everything now in this third party
there's like a third party to exist and
so you used to just be you and god or
you know you and the universe oh now
there's the cloud and now there is this
other
yeah there's this other
kind of mirror
but it's also like
a mirror that has
you feel like somebody's behind it with
a control a little bit you mean like
your social media presence
i just mean all of this
everything us recording it you know all
of it how we record everything yeah you
know
it's like i'll record this and then i'll
we never watch any of it later it never
means it's like
it's like
the moment i don't know it's just
something about
the moment used to matter more to us
because we didn't get so many of them
now it's like you can open your tick
tock and get a thousand moments from
other people and look at them all and
whatever and so
the moment doesn't have as much
pictures like we just take pictures and
like you get them developed and it was
an event to get them back and now
we don't even print pictures and we
don't hang pictures up they're just in
our phone and and that was all and then
yeah half of them 99 percent of will
never make it out never be seen again
and it's like it's just and then we're
all doing that instead of
being you know
i sometimes look at my own instagram
feed it's like we all work for sony kind
of
we kind of i mean i think we do i think
that's
or whoever
owns sony but it's like sometimes i look
at my own instagram feed and i'll get
jealous
of myself
be like god she's like
i'll forget i'm almost looking at myself
and i'll go back far enough where it
seems like a different person's life and
i'm like god she has it all she's
killing it and i'll have that moment of
like [ __ ] i'm doing it to myself like so
when i do it to other people it's gotta
be a lie because i remember that day i
was not happy and i look like i'm
killing it oh my god she does everything
she's so busy she works so hard i start
getting like threatened by my
past self
and then i always run the risk of like
when i post something like
i don't want to look like i'm like look
at me
but i also need people to look at me
yeah and i'm always mitigating this like
i hope people don't think i think i'm
cool
but i also want people to think i'm cool
but you can't
like my biggest fear that i always think
is like i just don't want female comics
mainly female comics to screenshot this
and text it to each other in a mass text
of like making fun of me and being like
look at how sweet she thinks she is she
looks she thinks she looks hot here
isn't that sad what does she what's
going on with her yeah that i that's
what i think about her really you think
about that huh oh yeah like my peers my
funny peers who i look up to
you know talking about me because we do
that i mean when and when i do it it's
always when i'm threatened it's always a
girl showing her body in a way that i'm
like oh my god i say i say oh this is so
sad but really i'm like i wish i could
show my body like that and be that free
and like not care what people think
who is more
threatening to women you think other
female comedian women or other men
comedians
i think it's i think it's a totally
different thing and so it's kind of hard
to compare the two because it's such a
different kind of threat but
um female comedians like we yeah we
definitely are threatened by one another
and i think it's it podcasts this more
conversational
nature of what we're doing now and
sharing and like uh it's made me a lot
more open about like my insecurities and
being able to tell when you're like i
need to mute i need to mute you
sometimes like i i'm sometimes i you
know
telling taylor tomlinson like i
like i sometimes don't watch your clips
because i don't
want to know how funny you are because
it makes me feel insecure or i like i i
being able to say it's so embarrassing
to say that but like it's just true and
it's not and it's not helping anything
but yeah i think that we
i know yeah there's tons of female
comics that have i mean my biggest
uh
my the worst interactions i've had in
comedy have been with female comics like
i was pretty badly bullied what like
in stand up when i first got into it
like almost bullied out of comedy when i
first started and
just looked up to this girl that was on
the scene like only wanted to be her had
nothing but reverence for her did not
even consider that i mean i was not a
stand-up that like thought i was good
when i first started i was not one that
was like hey asking the headliner to
watch my set like i was embarrassed
because i knew i was bad cause i just
started and i knew
that i was gonna get better but did you
work with the girl or no you know we
were in the same scene in st louis and
like she was the top dog on the scene so
funny a little bit older
and um
and she just hated me just hated me
thought i wasn't funny um
and then she also thought tommy
johnathan wasn't funny he was we were
kind of like the two young comics in st
louis and that's when i knew like oh i'm
probably funny because if she thinks
tommy's not tommy's just i knew tommy
was funny so i was like oh she just
thinks anyone who's funny funny is isn't
funny so that that made me feel better
but she
she just like spread lies that i slept
with people for stage time and i was a
[ __ ] virgin at the time like i
literally had never had sex and i was
she's saying i was sucking dick for
stage time when i was turning down stage
time i mean there were guys there was
headliners that came through and they
would offer me guest sets because they
probably liked me and i was funny enough
but you know have you ever blown an
indian guy before no
no
why
i don't know
no i haven't not yet
bucket list you got to get out there huh
it's weird sometimes i think i feel like
i can't even i never i feel like indian
people don't even have penises i feel
like i've never i don't know i never
even like even in porn i never even yeah
i guess i don't see much indian
representation in porn they don't indian
people yeah it's like i can't even
imagine i can't even imagine an indian
guy with a penis really yeah
i can for some reason i know i'm like
i'm into it
yeah
um what else we want to go through a
couple of news topics i'm trying right
there's anything else we want to talk
about i feel like yeah we covered
everything did we he was good i mean not
like it's been a good conversation how
do you think he's been zach all right
oh yeah you're about an hour 40 right
would you like tell us the truth zach
would you ever be like this this was not
your best and then just take it out
later i don't think you would i would
tell you the truth it would be good okay
no balls at all okay that's good i still
don't know if i'm no lull's like no lols
yeah l-u-l-o yes yes yes okay uh this is
the story we were talking about you're
talking about dms earlier dozier cat is
calling out noah uh this guy from
stranger things he plays uh will i guess
she dm'd him trying to hook up with the
guy who plays eddie on the show oh
you're familiar
and uh he shared their dm thread and she
called him out saying it's kind of
weasel [ __ ] so isn't this kid 17 that
she dm'd she yes but she's dming him
about
with the guy i still think it's like i'm
not saying that she's doing anything
inappropriate by dming a 17 year old but
the 17 year old is might screenshot your
conversation i mean he's a child so you
don't get mad and also it's a little
strange just dm the guy that you're into
this is the guy she was trying to hook
up with looks like wouldn't known a
writer
um okay i don't watch the show but so
what did she say i can't read that what
was her first okay
noah can you
sorry all my glasses on no you tell
josephs to hit me up
uh wait no does he have a girlfriend and
he goes lmao slide into his dms okay is
ig on twit or twitter he doesn't have a
dm to slide into okay so she she would
have
oh and then he sent her it
right here man see this one we call her
ma'am
ouch
that is cold and
i think it's strange she went through uh
why do you
cause sometimes people will do this
thing they will say hey what about your
friend but they're really trying to go
after you i don't know
that was my first thought too i don't
want to make any accusations i'm not
making accusations i mean that's just
very realistic
they got a brighter name tmz loves to
say or they got a writer age
these publications love to see a woman's
age
doji cat is 26. okay 26 sorry that's if
i was trying to get a
find out about a guy i would not go to
one of his children co-stars
to find out his thing and she also may
not have known how old this guy is yes
maybe but give it a go
yeah um yeah i think oh do you ever
worry about that girl's screenshot in
your stuff
what girl just any girls like you dm
maybe like you know fans yeah i've never
seen
i'd never have sent anything really in
obscene or nothing you know my buddy i
used to use a dick pic for you know two
times i sent it but it was my buddies my
friend jason oh that's good yeah did it
look like yours enough that it was like
okay to use or were you just like no i
think it was just you know i was
probably and you know driving or
something and i just was like
i need a dick pic hey
yeah and like hey can you yeah you know
and he's kind of he's 17. and he's
looking for work yeah
he's 17.
um let's get some real news is there any
cute adult news going on
oh yeah
oh yeah so elon's walking away from his
twitter deal twitter's threat
of all of our time talking about this
guy buying it really
why he had twin he's having twins
apparently with someone i know one of
the people who works how efficient is he
if he's having [ __ ] twins dude
you got to respect that guy efficiency
two birds
um
yeah i was just annoyed by this this is
like when people say they're going
they're retiring and then come out of
retirement i go we wasted so much energy
talking about you buying twitter and now
you're not it's like god can i get that
time back i know
but it's like you gotta set twitter free
it's just way too far left
like uh
it just caters to way too much of one
side of all views i feel like it just
seems like a because here's what i was
gonna make it better i hope he doesn't i
hope he gets it and then just kills it
oh that's yeah you're right i mean i
would i'm already pretty much done
because print is kind of dead yes so
once that's gone
what are we gonna do then it's just
gonna be video stuff i just think it
leaves us in a better spot because you
ca that's the only place you can easily
go
and just get all these other like quick
replies and like thoughts from p it's
like
you know the other um
social media platforms there's not as it
doesn't seem as easy to do that it's
like you know you can pull some comments
off my instagram feeds but that doesn't
feel like things don't catch fire right
ideas don't catch fire as quickly as
twitter right yeah yeah you're right
that's a good that's an interesting
perspective of he would have run it into
the ground yeah and now that's not gonna
happen right and then i don't know if
there's another one that gets people's
like where they can quote people as much
and as easily with print and so then it
like kind of sets us free from all that
ah so i feel like the best thing that he
could do
elon
if that's even your name which it
probably isn't but is buy it and kill it
you know
you know what do they say kill birds or
whatever or don't i don't know what they
say man but do it
what else do we have oh we got the roe
versus wade you guys they overturned
rovers wait was there more news
yeah i mean
louisiana is one of the places where
they just put in they had a they banned
it
yeah same with missouri where i live
i'm shocked kind of that this happened
yeah yeah it's sad
i for the first time ever
like
i
hearing people say
you know don't tell a woman what to do
with her body like the people that
believe abortion is like literally
killing a baby
like i i kind of see their point
if you believe that it's a baby at a
certain like late term abortion i don't
think any i wouldn't be for that and i'm
very pro and how late do they do it i
mean if it's there should be a line for
sure
but they can smile or something i think
you can't do it i don't know how they
see that
smile
you know what i'm saying though like if
it can like
yeah i mean there should be a line but
then it's like okay if you miss the day
before that line is that not like what
when is close what's the [ __ ] line
but there needs to be one but i do see
for the first time when when you know
people people on the pro-choice side are
saying
don't stop trying to control a woman's
body i mean
i believe that that is what they're
trying to do but i think that people
that are pro-life a lot of times they
just think you're killing babies and i
kind of sarah silverman used to have i
think a bit about like seeing little
girls with signs outside of an abortion
clinic you know picketing with their
parents and these little girls literally
think they're in their stabbing babies
which is like
of course you would be against that so i
don't i don't blame people that really
think it's a human life and
and are against that but i really think
this is about
like wanting to punish women for being
[ __ ] like it's like
huge you chose to you wanted to [ __ ]
someone and and i i don't know this is
me kind of going a step further i think
men want to punish women who don't [ __ ]
them so oh you want to [ __ ] someone
other than me you're gonna have to keep
the baby then you stupid [ __ ] i think
it's punishing women for being [ __ ] men
love [ __ ] when they're [ __ ] for them
but they [ __ ] hate [ __ ] when they're
[ __ ] for other men
and i say [ __ ] says like that's not what
i'm calling them that's what i think
meant i know what you're talking about
yeah what men think women just love
dicks
so much when really we have sex with men
a lot of times not because we love dicks
and us but because we want men to like
us and to protect us and we want
to give you guys what you want what does
it feel like does it feel like you're
having like your hat like you like after
you've eaten dinner does it just feel
like that but in your vagina
oh like like stuffed like literally like
thanksgiving like um
sometimes if you like have a lot of
stuff in you but no it does not feel
like it does not feel like you're like
oh i'm going to throw
yeah regurgitating um no it feels like
um i guess you just like don't know what
it's like i'm not trying to you guys
could feel like anally i'm just trying
to think about it that's the only thing
that we can share is what anal sex feels
like that's the only thing men and women
can go i know what you're talking about
which i kind of like about it is that
why you think women and gay men get
along well
no but that is interesting
um but i do i do like
i i do like talking to gay men about
anal sex because i enjoy it and i like
talking about like isn't it great and no
one like [ __ ] knows how great it is
and you guys like have to do it because
you don't have anything else but like
also like you're not doing it because
you're like i guess this is all we have
like it literally feels good or they
probably wouldn't do it but they should
be able to find another way to do it
also dude they can redesign a damn
[ __ ] living room in a heartbeat but
you can't
they don't need to find another way dude
it feels so good well then that's fine
yeah it really like if you find a way to
make it work it can really work for you
yeah
i am
not
not interested
i remember they had this group for a
while it was like trying to get they had
this gay group in our area that was
trying to get um
it was like we want to know what it
feels like to have a period or whatever
to like to partner with women so they
would wearing um tampons in their bottom
and for like four that's not what it
feels like to put in a tampon yeah that
was crazy man and they were like trying
to get you know
get people on board with that i was like
dude i ain't doing that no i would not
there's nothing worse than putting a
tampon up your vagina when you're not
bleeding it's like dr that's what it
would feel like up your [ __ ] that's
terrible yeah this guy yeah this group
was no this group was idiots they
weren't even i don't know if they even
had a uh
flag or they were sanctioned or whatever
it could have just been some pervy gay
dudes you know i cannot believe that
that's a thing like in solidarity oh
yeah really all right
oh my god
they used to have a lot of i'm trying to
think of like what it is they used to
have a group called i talked about
talking before with least of a group
called [ __ ] fist fights right that would
come to the bars in louisiana it was gay
men and they would come and fight and
fist fight and you'd pay to go watch
wait um okay so they would
but it was just like like boxing yeah
yeah that was way too good
and you would pay to go watch it yeah
we'd go there and drink you go and drink
and watch you know and it was a rod like
were they did were they enjoying it in
an erotic way did you think it was like
a sexual thing they were beaten if there
was anything straight left in any of
them i think they'd cheated out of each
other
was it like a self-hating thing you
think as gay men
because they were couldn't be themselves
i don't know it reminds me of this kid
that i grew up with and he dated this
gal who i think was a lesbian probably
early lesbian you know
and he would always he had like she
would like bruise his penis up and it
would like he would always show us and
it was like dude i don't think she likes
that yeah
[ __ ] i mean she's never heard of
anything like that i mean she bruises i
mean yeah
this kid bradley and he used to be a
referee did he like it
because there's something he was happy
that somebody was touching his penis but
i think he wish it was somebody else oh
man
yeah it looked like she had just you
know that is the thing about penises
like you just asked me what it feels
like to have a penis in you like you
don't you can't understand what that
feels like and you even said before like
just loitering with the just you know
having a penis between your legs like
that is wild to me that you guys have
that just like swinging
all the time and that also the thing
that blew my mind about penises when i
first encountered them was that they go
i thought a boner just was like 90
degrees i didn't know they could go like
all the way up and i love that they can
just be like i love a flaccid penis i
love playing with them i think they're
so fun i like to just hold
them when they're flasked and i know
guys don't like that because it's like
oh i'm small but i just love i just
think they're so fun while i'm laying
down if i squeeze my penis yeah for long
enough
i'll go to sleep it's comforting it's
good yeah
it's good the same way i think women do
that with our uh tits just like hold it
the guy just gets to go do this
and it feels like i get why that is
exciting to men and i just get to see it
well it feels like you're holding on to
like
it's like the chain of life a little bit
you're like hugging you're nurturing
yourself i like again i didn't get
touched enough as a kid i don't think
and i in the right way you know yeah and
so yeah same i think let's look at a
little bit more yeah so if this starts
to happen though if they shut down the
uh oh yeah what's gonna happen do you
think like how do you see that playing
out
just
women getting them illegally right it's
just gonna be something for the elite
they're just or
and they're just gonna
do it in unsafe methods and so there's
still gonna be abortion but it's just
women are gonna die streets back all
right [ __ ] that is so [ __ ] funny
it's gonna get
risque out there
[Music]
honestly that makes me feel so happy
that
out of all of that all of this that
makes me so sad
you can make that joke and like that
wouldn't exist without
this happening and i'm grateful that
that joke can exist it doesn't make it
worth it but that that fact that i'm
always i'm gonna tell everyone about
this joke
and that will bring a little bit of joy
to this very scary time to just go back
streets back all right
damn yeah with this abortion stuff man
what if they start going back to those
way like
no it's so
yeah i've never had one um and it
doesn't look like i'm ever gonna be able
to i live in missouri so i can't get one
anymore
but i you know you just
i'd be i'd i'd find a way so people are
then gonna drive across state lines to
get them if i needed to yeah there's
going to be like little abortion wagons
or whatever like you'll
see like a train of just like
spent broads rolling through town you
know
you know just like legs hanging over
this out the side of the thing it's just
like we're taking them off yeah we're
taking them all up north you know
i know
oh man um yeah no the girl you can go to
like the underground snail rose oh my
god oh my [ __ ] god
there's just gonna be greyhound buses
full of freaking just just breast milk
leaking out the back of it
just charter just like the [ __ ] uh
gestation charters llc just like all
kinds of
crazy llc's opening up
just trucking these friends damn it theo
stop
just trucking these
[ __ ] serving broads
oh out
you're contributing to the narrative
it's so sad it's ridiculous man it's
like but have you ever had a scare have
you ever had
i'm sure i don't no like i won't even
have sex two times in a row with the
woman because i don't want the
possibility of
since i got off a first time of any more
semen getting in there oh my god it's
like you're like
buying two lottery tickets you don't
want to double your chances oh yeah i
don't want to single my chances whoa
dude do you pull out is that your
way out do you use condoms i don't know
i don't regularly use them but i have
used yeah for sure yeah but i mean i use
them when it's necessary yes you know
yes
man but you're rich now man if i like
jumped off a building and landed into a
vagina on the street yeah i would use a
condom
okay but like do you worry that girls
are going to try to keep it in try to
find the com put it in them
uh uh i go i'll go to i'll drake puts
hot sauce in his condoms i'll keep it
far away
oh i'm from louisiana dude i wouldn't be
shocked if people have done a lot of
that [ __ ]
i wouldn't be surprised if uh there's
already acid in it
some of the bouillabaisse out there
um you gotta worry about that [ __ ] i
know man girls do crazy stuff
i just don't even want to ejaculate
anymore i just don't even know if it's
safe probably best for your mind not to
like
it [ __ ] you up go back to my old
neighborhood and just
yard out for dad
i get up i mean all right your dad's
still alive no no okay god i really want
to get to the bottom of what that
reasoning was
[Music]
just giving it back to the earth yeah it
wasn't it wasn't about shaming you
though it wasn't like don't you [ __ ]
do this again no he just said that's
gods he put it back
oh [ __ ]
but that's how it is
but yeah what do you think will happen
would you go get one still you think or
would you do you think it's going to
create because i guess if the idea is i
get how
religious people i get if they are
overtly religious and valid religious
i get some of their
like you're saying i get their minds i
can understand people's mindsets on it
yeah right i can too i can even
understand the mindsets of the men who
are just like
god women if they really were able to
harness their sexuality they could
destroy us we should
probably [ __ ] put some sanctions on
this because
you know
bill clinton sacrifice think of what
bill clinton sacrificed to get a [ __ ]
like really think about that because his
balls were full one day
and a flirty skirt walked by the office
and he sacrificed everything that he had
worked so he got to the top position and
he put it all in the line for a [ __ ]
and then another one and then a [ __ ]
cigar up a [ __ ] like if women were
really able to harness what we could do
to
that that power how defenseless men are
to wanting to come
we could take over like that's some
powerful [ __ ]
so what of course i'd want to control
that if i were a man and saw my my
livelihood and my
sense of power and self being threatened
by
women and and their bodies i'd want to
[ __ ]
try to if i was a bad person and wanted
to like a selfish person a narcissist
i'd want to control that i even
understand that logic and i think that's
where it comes from
but some guys i think honestly he also
was just in the white house i think like
he just got in the oval office
i think there's something about guys
like if you just get into a new room
it's like you want to kind of ejaculate
in it like dude i'll stay at a hampton
inn bro and i'm not in there 40 minutes
before i'm like
i gotta spill out in here wait you just
said you don't like to put out your like
you but you want it out oh i'm talking
about as a child you know right okay
okay but as an adult i think as a man
you're you're like you know
i'll save your claim yeah oh dude i'm 75
minutes i'm
you know where's where's the most common
a hotel room based on when you have come
in hotel rooms
comforter like the top sheet no on the
floor i think on the floor okay
good to know
what do you think
yeah with i would think like i would
just like if i were
even myself i just kind of like smear it
on like the pillowcase or like wipe my
hand like on a pillow i'm not using and
just like something i know is gonna get
washed oh
or like a toil just like rub it in the
sheets dude one time this girl had
stayed over with me at a hotel this
awesome girl
and
she had gotten her menstrual cycle yeah
and
i didn't know i had to go to the
cleaning lady and say like hey you know
i don't know what to do do i
pay for this you know oh that's nice of
you or whatever yeah you know oh there
they got it they don't and she was like
i don't know where she was from another
country right yeah and so i didn't know
what i was like trying to like i was
like
the
and i was just like how does he
you know yes
and uh
and i don't think she understood i did
give her 20 bucks yeah yeah that's good
throw 20 on if it's messy and looks like
a crime scene like yeah hush money so
what do you think is going to happen
because i was in uh santa monica the
other day having breakfast with my
friend
who we've talked about having a kid
together also
and uh
she
oh and a parade went by a
get out of our [ __ ] parade it was like
a protesting parade and it was really
cool to see people protest and it was
real creative that was really cool
um
is get out of our [ __ ] talking to men
or talking to the baby that they have in
there
[Laughter]
okay so a parade's going by you're with
this lady that you might have a baby
with as an and as his friend friends i
like it okay and uh
and yeah this lady was going i mean
there was a lady just screaming get out
my body you know get out my bus
and i was like i could not even imagine
anybody ever being in this ladies
vagina ever yes but i'm not saying that
it hasn't and i might say i have no idea
what her life is like
[Music]
but
i was like whatever whatever gets out of
her [ __ ] i wish it would get into her
mouth because
this lady is a [ __ ] guy yeah
sometimes it's like i think that women
get so mad
that they feel like it's like trying to
silence us and you know put and control
us so like what's the opposite of that
being so loud being so offensive
like
doing doing the opposite like i don't
know when i was on the road with bert
when roe v wade got overturned and i had
already had planned on taking my shirt
off at some point on the tour with bert
as just like an homage to bert just like
a funny thing that because he kind of
joked like it'd be funny if you took
your shirt off and i was like
oh yeah like i never do that but i was
like i would do that that's kind of
funny and then roe v wade got overturned
and i don't know i was we were in the
south and it was kind of like i think i
told someone on his tour like i might
like take my toffee and they're like you
have to cover your nipples like like
it's we could go to jail like you could
get arrested for that and for some
reason that like
so bert can show his nipples but i can't
like it made me mad and i kind of and i
ended up picking him up for my shirt and
it was just to make bert laugh and like
make everyone laugh but it was like
there was something about it being
naughty and being like
it's
first of all i didn't want anyone to
think i was doing it because i want to
like look hot or like want to titillate
i was really doing it for laughs and
just a fun thing but it felt a little
bit like
[ __ ] you like sorry if you if you're
turned on by me or if these are like a
burden to you like it felt like a [ __ ]
you in a way that it didn't intend kind
of like a bra burning like i'm gonna be
loud and proud and like sorry if this
makes you uncomfortable sorry if there
are kids here look at my [ __ ] tits
and i had a brawn it was totally covered
but there was something about like man
if i wanted to take my shirt off and
show my nipples i couldn't that's kind
of weird
that is weird to me that like that's
super weird they there's like they've um
on tv i think there was like a a trans
person getting top surgery
and
they like you know as their before
surgery
flat-chested uh pre-op they show the
whole nipple and everything the second
they put an implant in blur like the
second it becomes a woman's tit
not okay and there's just and i get it
because
it is distracting like
we don't want to turn men on and like
they're they're
i'm not i
gotta get some tit out there but yeah i
really do feel like there's something in
me that's like man i want to [ __ ] do
a topless special not because i want to
be like look at my awesome tits but to
be like [ __ ] deal with it and if bert
can do it and it is freeing it's fun to
take your shirt off on stage there's
something so vulnerable about it like
we're talking about stripping there's
something like
i don't [ __ ] care what you guys think
of me take me in look at me i like
myself there's something yeah there's
there was something about it that wasn't
look at me i'm hot it was a little bit
of a [ __ ] you and i don't know how to
define that but it's i think i had
something in common with that [ __ ]
woman screaming get out of my posse
yeah
like yeah that is funny when you go i
think i don't even think you could carry
a child ma'am at your age but like i
like no one's no one's talking about
your [ __ ] and they have it for a while
but i like that you're so upset about it
and you're making you're ruining my
lunch that's uh you know what and now
that i now that you say that i'm like
you're right you're like if you're gonna
protest it has to be it has to be
annoying right it has to be in your face
like i always i'm vegan and i post vegan
[ __ ] all the time and then i'll say this
that lady did a [ __ ] good job yeah
we're talking about it now like it's
making it
because as a vegan like i i [ __ ] used
to hate vegans they're so annoying i
thought they always thought they were
better than us constantly reminding us
of like animal suffering putting things
in your face that you're like jesus
christ
and then one day it [ __ ] worked they
got through they were annoying enough
that i go honestly i can't deny this
anymore i gotta go vegan so i i post it
all the time and
it is a little shamey of like listen i
was once you too i used to think this
way i used to be in denial of it but
tell me watch this video and try to eat
a pig today later today and see what
happens so because it worked on me
people being obnoxious i used to make
fun of vegans i used to [ __ ] hate
them resent them oh god uh and now i'm
one of them and it's because they were
so obnoxious so you got to be loud
that's a good point you got to be loud
got to be annoying you got to have
people hate what you're doing because
otherwise you're not going to get
noticed yeah
especially these days but it's hard
because all i want is to be liked i
don't ever want to be annoying i hate
that
i know huh i never want to be people
think like i she thinks she's cool or
like she thinks she's
yeah i just i i and it's it's you know
it's ironic because i
talk into a microphone for a living and
no one else can talk and i make make
people listen to me but i'm so scared of
people thinking that
i'm annoying or that i want attention or
something when clearly i [ __ ] do i
know
that's fascinating well it used to be a
different level of manageability before
there was social media stuff it was just
like i'm good at my craft come see me do
it and now every time you put something
out there's a risk
that it's like maybe
they'll see
that i'm not and they won't come see me
do what i'm actually good at i don't
post any stand-up clips literally none
i've done three hour specials
four half hours like i have hours of
stand up i could be all over tick tock i
could kill it with my clips i cannot put
them out there because i'm scared that
they're gonna look closely and see i'm
actually not talented
whereas if you just see
trailers for things or you see pictures
of me doing stand-up
who knows i can be the [ __ ]
i know i'm funny i know i kill i
but then there's a a part of me that
thinks i'm uh imposter you know that i'm
a charlatan that i'm tricking people
yeah
so and it's scary for me to even admit
that because i'm like please don't go
look closely please just just think i'm
funny like don't go analyze it
yeah i do the same thing to comics like
you know you watch some comics and you
go god this [ __ ] guy sucks and look
at all his tricks and you like i'm
scared of people doing the same thing
that i do i gotta work on what i do in
my judgment of people and then the self
and then me worrying about what everyone
else thinks will go away if i stop
because i'm just doing it i'm scared of
doing of people doing to me exactly what
i do to them
damn
right yeah look i appreciate your
honesty were we ever gonna date i don't
think we ever were we never even talked
about it no
and it's like
uh but i've always like
just i mean you're the funniest [ __ ]
person and you're real as [ __ ] and i
love that you talk you're like anyone
who's in recovery and struggles with
that [ __ ] i'm like so yeah i'm just like
so into it and because it's like we have
to operate on a different level of
honesty than
a lot of our peers like you think you're
honest and then you get in recovery and
you're like well i wasn't really being
and i think it's like carried over into
my stand up i don't know if it helps
sometimes though what do you mean
because it gives you more stuff to
evaluate your stuff on
like or doing podcasting sometimes it's
like man now there's so much more like
you know sometimes i used to think i was
being kind of like
i'm sharing what's going on with myself
and then then when i get really like
judgmental it's like of myself or like
in fear it's like man look at all this i
can't believe i did this to like i've
put all this out that you know it's like
i don't know it gives like
it gives that fear another like punch of
like
you shouldn't have done this you know
yes you're too overexposed and then they
use it against you sometimes you'll get
vulnerable and say something that like
you're like you know what i'm gonna put
this out there and
share this thing i don't usually share
because i'm with my friend and it just
feels safe and then
you find that fans will watch that and
the second they get they they they start
using it again they'll say like we're
worried about you are you suicidal again
like you said you were on rogan or like
and then you go or they'll
you know yeah that i i just have found
that sharing too much peop i forget i
share certain stuff and then it comes
back to haunt me with fans just knowing
too much and they don't they shouldn't
know things my only my best friends or
my sponsors no but for some reason i'm
giving them that why
and why wouldn't they feel close to me
of course they would they're listening
in their ear to me say like things that
their closest friends don't even tell
them
of course they feel like they they're
worried about me i hate when people
worry about me man [ __ ] oh yeah isn't
that the [ __ ] worst yeah it's like
i'll [ __ ] worry about me you idiot
yeah yeah i worry you don't know me and
you're trying to get closer to me but
and i get it i've been worried about it
it's like i'll [ __ ] worry about me
you know it's like i'm i'm the one who
worries about me that's where my thought
is it's just like i've worried about me
this long yeah i don't need you to come
do it that's where my thoughts and it
strikes me as pity and it strikes me as
someone like talking about me behind my
back me being like a i don't i don't
know i just like growing up in high
school and having like an eating
disorder always having people having
meetings behind your back of like what
are we gonna do about nikki like and
then finding out later like the whole
school is meeting about me and all my
friends are having conferences with my
parents and call like that kind of [ __ ]
you could have been eating one wiener
nobody would have said you know what i'm
saying there's nothing i would have done
a demo in the [ __ ] living room in
front of our parents
yeah but there's no conference about
that no there's never you're starved
from nutrition people were like we gotta
discuss this yeah i was getting too hot
but you're out there carving up on
freaking little henry's nut bags
okay nobody says a word any more news we
got to discuss zach or what
i mean you kind of hit the big hits i
can pull something else the big hits we
got doja
don't you can't slide and that rover i
just wonder if it's gonna go all the way
through i just i wonder if this is also
becoming a thing where it's like
everything's kind of not working now
it's like the airlines aren't working
right like
the everything that the the post office
doesn't work anymore yeah it's like
every kind of like the environment right
yeah
the air outside it's so
so hot yeah and this is just the
beginning it's [ __ ] scary
everything's breaking down
yeah and we're all kind of just like
pretending that it's not like we're
joking about it we're like commenting on
it here and there but it is
terrifying things are fall like it's
like it feels like or also
things are just kind of going along and
there's so much media that is about fear
that's right that's what i can't i can't
figure out
which one it is
i think it's probably a mixture of both
but i think for
i don't know it's
i really don't want to read about the
climate anymore i just there's no good
news there's never any [ __ ] good news
about polar bears there's never an
animal news story that like
makes you feel good yeah there's maybe
like that dodo account or whatever and
you read about a rehabilitated pit bull
or something like a [ __ ] donkey he's
friends with oh yeah
parrots are the other day ahead of two
parrots killing a cat on twitter yeah i
mean it's just [ __ ] unreal so hot
thinking about having a kid i'm sorry
i'm s
you can't not have a kid cause it's so
hot dude get your [ __ ] lazy ass off
you can't not have a kid because it's
too hot to have a kid they're not gonna
be able to go outside and you're gonna
have to hang out with them all the
[ __ ] time
that's what listen this isn't about me
being like my child will never get to
experience a safari and get to swim in
the ocean it's like i'm just i don't
want to deal with a child during like
the end times and i don't i don't want
to go i don't want to be around a kid 24
hours a day in a [ __ ] bunker
without electricity
that's what sucked would suck get out oh
my bunker yeah that's what i would be
yelling yeah dude those are the kids we
need to get rid of like four-year-olds
who cares about the damn zygotes
i'm like have you spent 40 minutes with
a two-year-old
that's we need like a two-year after
pill dude that's the [ __ ] oh my
god
yeah i want to adopt like a teenager
yeah i think i'd be a great mom for like
a
eight eight and up i want to talk to
kids about life i want to like listen to
their feelings i just i can't like i
don't want to play i don't really want
to play i don't want to go outside
it's too [ __ ] hot
too hot to adopt that's your new special
that has to be your new special um she
has a new special coming up on hbo max
it's called good clean filth comes out
july 16th on saturday and it'll be it's
on hbo on saturday july 16th and then
we'll be on hbo max and then yeah f boy
island season two f-boy island season
two yeah and um and i have a daily
podcast and a daily podcast too yeah
monday through thursday nikki glazer
podcast wow it's daily too huh yeah
because weekly i don't know
every time they would come up it'd be
like oh god [ __ ] another like it would
just it would feel like i'd do one and
then be like yes i get a break and then
the next one would just show up and i'd
be like god so i was just like just make
this every day so it's not something you
dread it's just the way life is
and i love it it's my favorite thing
to do yeah
it's good i'm grateful you're here
thanks so much i'm grateful that you're
here thank you for having me theo yeah
that's a lot of fun
so fun nicki glazer
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
pants
and these whales that i've been riding
on they want something that they're damn
they're gone
[Music]